you wrote a th000 words a day for 600
days in a row yeah what the
[__] I'm never someone that's content to
go at the same Pace as everyone else you
set the pace right do you want this to
take multiple years sometimes it should
and sometimes it's best for you or do
you want to get it done very quickly
that's been probably a defining factor
in my life that's absolutely insane this
week's episode is with Nathan Barry
who's the founder and CEO of convertkit
a software company valued at over $100
million and Nathan's story is absolutely
Fant fantastic he started off working a
normal job realized he didn't
particularly enjoy his normal job taught
himself to do design and code type stuff
and started building apps for the iPhone
app store and then later on he
transitioned away from that to build his
software business I had these three
posters on my wall in like my first real
home office and there were the three
mantras of create every day teach
everything you know and work in public
and that was like my equivalent of of
show your work I guess the way to put it
is it is simple but not easy Y and so if
you get clear with yourself that like
okay okay I am setting out to do
something that is in fact very difficult
and I have to design my day around
making sure that this can happen this
has to become my number one priority in
my business then at that point you can
actually make it
happen oh by the way in case you have
not yet heard my book is about to come
out it's called Feelgood productivity
how to do more what matters to you and
it's a book that I've been working on
for the last 3 years now it's being
published at the end of December 2023
but pre-orders are actually available
and I know people don't like
pre-ordering the book but if you do
pre-order the book and you email me your
receipt you will get completely free
access to a live exclusive event that
I'm hosting in the first weekend of
January of 2024 and this is a live
online Workshop all about annual
planning goal setting and reflection and
so I'm going to be facilitating a group
with hopefully hundreds of people from
all around the world and we're going to
be going through how to figure out what
to do with our life and how to turn that
into goals for the year and how to build
systems and how to be consistent with
stuff and how to make sure that we are
enjoying the journey along the way that
is purely exclusively available for
people who pre-order the book as a thank
you for our little community so if you
want to check it out you can check out
the book you can maybe consider
pre-ordering it the link will be down in
the video description Nathan welcome to
the podcast thank you so much for coming
this is going to be so much fun I'm
excited um so I'd love to start off with
your backstory um how did you come to
care about making
money yeah okay so I grew up in a family
where there wasn't a lot of money uh my
dad worked in a Ministry and uh everyone
you know supported by donations and so
uh I actually grew up and house or like
was born in a house up in the mountains
outside of boisey and and uh you know it
was like a tiny house before tiny houses
were cool um now I have a tiny house as
my office and it's much cooler than the
one that I grew up in but
um yeah so I watch like the struggle of
money or the lack of money be like kind
of a defining factor of childhood you
know like there was always enough food
but you know not much more than that and
so growing up I watched uh my parents
fight about money and watch the stress
that that caused and then them
ultimately divorce
and somewhere along there I realized
like oh you can actually make money I
think it was
probably oh maybe late high school early
college when I first started reading
like Jason freed and dhh from base camp
and Jason talked about how making money
is a skill and you can get better with
better at it over time and that stood
out to me cuz the point that he was is
you wouldn't expect to sit down at the
piano and be able to play like some
amazing song without practice and in the
same way you wouldn't expect or you
shouldn't expect to be able to sit down
and you know start a company in it to do
fantastic and so really it's the
combination of not one skill but like a
thousand little skills just in the same
way that music is right you you know
there's music theory and timing and
everything else and and business is you
know uh confidence in sales and
marketing and pricing and you know all
the audience building and so when I
understood that that making money was a
skill that you get better at with
practice and I was like okay I'm going
to be you know the like someone else
could be the child prodigy in music like
that is what I'm going to be Absolut as
good as I can at making money so even
hearing you say that that making money
is a skill it's and I I've I noticed
myself having a bit of a moment of
surprise I'm like oh yeah I I guess it
is because I guess it's it's obvious
that playing the piano is a skill but
it's not that it's it's weirdly not that
obvious that making money is a skill
well I think you can't see it right I
can't sit down I'm like I'm like Ollie
let me let me just watch you make money
you know it it's it's very indirect I
can watch you play the piano and I could
watch you you know do scales or or build
up you know these individual things and
put it together into a song and and all
of that but um the skills of making
money are a little bit more abstract and
we tend to assign them to things like um
oh she's good at sales because she has
that natural Charisma right or uh you
know he's just gifted with being a good
copywriter but these are all skills that
are learned and and sometimes people are
better at them than others right if you
grew up in a family that uh music was
all around you uh then you might uh take
more naturally or you might have more of
a natural ability towards some of those
things in the same way that someone
might have more of a natural ability um
towards sales or marketing or some of
these things things but all of them have
to be learned think about the first time
you tried to sell something on the
internet right what prod like how do you
do that when I tried to do it you know
I'm like ClickBank e junkie how do you
even get money on like from a person to
me and now there's a lot more tools uh
for it and it's easier but it's still
something that you have to learn right
uh creating a landing page for the first
time that is a skill right if you look
at the first landing pages that a lot of
content creators make they're terrible
because they don't understand that the
that the headline should should capture
attention but once you know that you
never unlearn it and so now you know
years later after you've been doing this
you're like I don't know I made a
landing page in a half hour and of
course it captured attention like it of
course it checked all these boxes in the
same way uh that you know using music as
the analogy right like you your timing
is good because you have learned that
and so I think that's the thing that we
miss and and it's hard as a beginner
where you're like it just it feels so
unknown and there's so many skills and
then someone who's been doing it a long
time just sits down and it seems so
natural because they have rehearsed for
in many cases a decade or several
decades yeah that's such a good point I
think so I I made my first landing page
when I was like 13 years old advertising
my web design Services we'll put it up
on screen if we can find if I can find
that screenshot cuz I still have it it's
just so funny um it was like you know
want a website for your business or your
life call this number and I put my home
number on it like made up some names
like UIA Web Solutions like some shitty
agency y um but then sort of 15 years
later when we when we're whipping up
landing pages for our products that are
doing sort of millions in revenue and
the team is just like looking at me
being like whoa how did you just do that
and I'm like oh I mean it's just like
you know whether it's webflow or
WordPress or good job it's all the same
kind of stuff you just like put it
together it's just like oh you know this
obviously the headline and there's like
this whole thing that goes into it but
seeing it as a skill is I guess
something I've not really not really
considered yeah and it's really the
combination of a lot of different skills
right if you learn web design that's
some point in there you probably learned
about uh user experience and and did
some user research and you know you
understand like the flow of eye tracking
and like ey movement over a page it
tends to go in a z format where people
um you know at least in in uh
English-speaking uh countries tend to
read left to right and then they'll
angle down and so if you want to call to
action you're going to typically put it
like if I want you to to do something
that's going to be in the lower right
and you know that at one point that was
something that I learned and that was
probably 15 years ago and now it's just
very intuitive and so when I come across
a page and someone's like oh this isn't
converting well it's like okay well
let's flip the left and right columns
let's you know let's change this
headline your there's so many design
things as well design is one of these
skills that um I feel very like blessed
to have learned early on because it just
applies to everything and someone's like
oh this page isn't converting I'm like
well yeah it's because everything has
the same visual weight right let's make
your headline a a little bit bigger that
sub headline let's make it a bit smaller
you know you don't have to use black
text for everything right let's go to
like a 70 80% gray you know and you just
add this level of quality and polish to
it that becomes very natural when when
you do it and it spreads out through
everything um and I see that so often
with content creators where they put out
this amazing content especially written
content right they say words matter
words are the most important thing and
they are but how you package them
changes how they're perceived and that's
what's going to drive if someone
actually really engages with it so the
number of ebooks that I come across
where the content is so good and the
actual packaging and and design of it is
so bad and I'm like you're missing out
on probably half of your audience
because they're just like oh you know
the packaging isn't very good and yes I
am judging a book by its cover or
whatever else and and I'm moving on
because if they didn't put that level of
care into one aspect of it the cont
that's probably not that great either
and and so is in my team we we still use
your Authority ebook that you made like
10 years ago as like this is what a PDF
should look like cuz like we often like
package up things as like worksheets and
workbooks and stuff YouTuber Academy and
things I'm just like sending them
authority. PDF to be like yeah this is a
good PDF don't just make it a simple
like Microsoft like Apple Pages and
print yeah that was
actually uh Apple used to have a product
around making uh ebooks specifically and
I'm trying to remember what it was cuz
that wasn't done in Pages or something
else it was done in this other product
that they've since discontinued because
it was like for the whole iBook format
and all of that and I found that that
was the best design tool that wasn't
like uh Adobe in design or something you
know like a full a full thing but that
that's funny that you keep doing that is
good um okay so just sticking on this
IDE of making money as a skill um just
for one one moment um a lot of
people so it's it sounds like like the
way the way that we're talking about it
it's right now it's it's almost a given
that we're talking about having your own
business and learning all the skills to
making money within your own business
which I think is also a niche way of
thinking about making money because for
like 99.99% of the population making
money is a thing that's tied to your job
I wonder like what are what are your
thoughts on like having a job versus
having a business and I guess in your
early days what took you down the that
the having a business route rather than
the getting a job route well so if you
think about the ability to increase your
earnings in a job you're fairly limited
right the default is you're going to get
some um cost of living increase right 3
to 5% a year maybe um now it won't outpa
inflation but
uh you know or you're going to have to
jump roles and level up right and we've
seen lot a lot of people and I had that
in my own career where the first job
that I had was making 60,000 a year as a
designer the first professional job I
worked at Wendy's doing uh Food Services
you know did plenty of web design and
all that uh as well but in any job for
the most part your earnings are going to
be very closely tied to your
time and you can't really separate those
and so I wanted to get to the point not
where I was making 50,000 100,000
200,000 a year I want to get to the
point where I making millions a year and
there just aren't that many
jobs where you're at that level there
actually are but not in the same not in
the worlds that I grew up in yeah right
I didn't grow up in the worlds of uh
private equity and you know I dropped
out of out of school like I didn't
finish High School dropped out of
college um and uh and so I wasn't like
oh you know let's go to Stanford and do
private Equity or or you know some
Finance thing or or anything like that
and so I was looking for ways that I
could earn you know far more and so I
think that's where I've taken it on the
um on the earning side is
inputs and outputs are completely can be
completely disconnected um when it comes
to so why not just think you know what
I've got a 60k job as a designer I'm
living in Boise Idaho which is fairly
low cost of living as my understanding
yeah it used to be it used to be I can I
can live a chill life I go go to work do
my 9 to5 come home I chill like why not
be content with that lot in
life that I mean that's a good question
I I think I've always been a Creator
like always made things and
so yeah I'm I'm constantly learning and
constantly making and
uh I like I think I just get really
really bored and I actually I spent two
and a half years working as a software
designer at the
startup and I had done freelance web
design for a couple of years uh and then
in
200 the beginning of 2009 so at least in
the US the economy was down like crazy
and all my clients like stop hiring
except for this one company and they you
know they're like hey we have even more
work actually do you want to just come
on full-time and so I joined them and
were there for two and a half years and
during that time I watched them raise a
ton of venture
capital uh I think I was employeed 15 it
maybe peaked at 70 or 80 employees and
then they did a few rounds of layoffs
and you know I eventually left um but
that was
something I remember going through that
process and
finding that I was losing a lot of the
skills that I valued about myself right
you I think it's really interesting if
you were to write down like what do you
value about yourself and there's
probably some things you know uh like
how you are as a friend and other things
that are like really good but then then
there's others that are you value about
yourself that are um maybe a little more
dangerous uh in the sense that they're
they're tied to things that you control
less so one thing that I value uh about
myself and
valued a lot then is how productive I
was how fast I was when I worked food
service at Wendy's uh it was all about
speed right how can you maintain this
bar of quality and go very very fast
because when we work the drive-thru
there's this big timer over the window
and it's basically the amount of time
from when a car starts their order to
when they're driving away with their
food right and we're trying to go we
went under 60 seconds wow um and so we'd
like call up at the stores and be like
okay for the lunch rush you know uh
we're going to get 58 seconds what are
you going to get they're like okay we're
going to get H I don't know 57 you know
you're like trying to compete with them
and it's just a friendly thing but we
got very very fast and efficient and
when I did web design when I went from
working per hour to working per project
then I realized that for the first time
the speed and efficiency benefits me
when you work at Wendy's it's like wow
you're so fast let's have a raise from
$6 an hour to 650 an hour you're like I
think I worked really hard and you know
that's not benefiting me
and hourly work you know maybe as a web
designer it's $50 an hour or something
um but when I went to oh let me charge
$2,000 for a project then I was like
wait the faster I am at this my hourly
rate increases substantially and so then
I was like okay how do I template things
how do I stay super focused and all of
this and then when I went and joined
this company I realized that I was
losing those skills because no one else
in that environment cared that much
about working working quickly especially
as the company started to struggle you
know um there was that first round of
layoffs people let would spend time like
standing around the pool table uh
complaining about how they didn't get
paid enough and I was like none of us
are even working right now you know and
so what I actually did is I realized
that I in my design coding abilities I
realized I lost the skill of speed right
I didn't hone and refine it over the
previous two years and I I had lost that
I would sit down to work on a side
project uh at night and I realized like
I wasn't very good at Focus I couldn't
you know something that used to take me
2 hours to code out was now taking me 3
four 5
hours and so what I actually decided to
do is I one I decided I was not going to
lose that part of my identity yeah right
like that would be a valuable skill I
like no no I'm not losing that and so I
ended up switching switching my desk uh
from one that was like in the middle of
a big room like someone else had left
and so there was one way off in the
corner and I got that and I decided that
I was going to be the best employee on
that team and I was going to do it in 3
hours a day and I was going to spend all
the rest of my time like learning to
design and code iOS apps uh you know
other things right and so instead of
moving at the slow pace of everyone else
and like just turning into someone that
I didn't want to be um I was like okay I
still need this job but I'm Gonna Knock
Out all of my work make sure you know
I'm ahead of schedule and everything and
then I'm going to be in a place where
you can't see my my monitor and I'm
going to be studying how to build iOS
apps and I'm going to be coding on my
own side projects and I rebuilt that
that speed and that ability to work
quickly and so then six three to six
months later when I left uh that company
you know I had a uh a stable of you know
iOS apps that were making money and I
had new skills that I built up um but
yeah that that's the thing of like I'm
never someone that's content
to go at the same Pace as everyone else
what do you think was it about you that
sort of made you different from the
other people in your team who were
content to chill for 8 hours a day and
complain about how much they were being
paid I just love the Jos between those
two things where I'm like it'd be one
thing if we were the absolute best team
but we weren't I've always wanted to get
the most out of my time and and move as
quickly as possible so I was
homeschooled and I grew up um
with my parents really teaching me that
I set the pace so I remember two
different things um the first is I was
probably 11 or 12 years old and we lived
uh up in the mountains and so I remember
just the most beautiful snow coming down
in the winter and I loved sledding and
I'm just I I've got you know algebra
that I'm supposed to work on and I'm
looking outside and like the snow looks
so good and I just can't focus on it and
I think I complained to my mom about her
and and she goes you know you just have
a set amount of work to get done it
doesn't have to take an hour or five
hours or whatever like you don't have to
sit here and do school till 3 p.m. you
just need to be be here and do school
until it's
done
and like that is the most focused
11-year-old you've probably ever seen
where I was like okay great let's get it
all done all that you know my little
brother's and like no I don't have time
for this like I got to I got to get my
school done so I can go sledding and I
think like an hour or two later I was
out there sledding because I realized
that like if you cut out all the
complaining when you're studying math
and all that like it goes remarkably
faster um so that was the first thing
where realized I'm like okay uh it it's
not a fixed amount of time and the
second thing is growing up I spent the
most time with my two older siblings and
so because I like tagged along with them
and their friends all of our friends
were older than me and so that wasn't
really a problem through like kind of
Junior High uh High School ages but
really once I was just starting high
school they were all thinking about
going off to college and that's when I
realized like oh this age Gap is going
to become very noticeable because um
sure they're only two three years older
than me but then like I'm going to be
finishing out high school and they're
going to be uh going to be gone at
college and so I went back to my mom and
I said you know it's high school like
a fixed amount of work or a fixed amount
of time and so it's basically the same
question that I asked her or that she
had brought up about you know math
homework on a snowy day but applied to a
bigger chunk of time and you know she
had homeschooled my older siblings who
had already finished high school and and
so she said no I have I have the exact
curriculum you know that you're going to
go through you can graduate high school
whenever you complete this
curriculum and so I remember thinking
that we we would do these drives from
Boise to Seattle which is about eight or
nine hours uh to go visit family every
summer and that was before iPads and uh
all of that and so I remember thinking
like I'm really bored on this drive and
I'm really bored when I do math so why
don't I just combine these two and I
would do like a month's worth of math
lessons on a drive over to Seattle and I
had my older brother sitting next to me
and you know whenever I got stuck he
could help me and and we' go through
that
and so uh from when I was 13 to when I
was 15 I finished all of the like High
School curriculum and then I graduated
just a little before turning 16 uh and
then I was off going to college and all
of that so really the idea of you set
the pace Derek cers talks about this in
his book anything you want how he went
through Berkeley School of Music very
very quickly um because of this one
Professor that was like let me teach you
a semester's worth of music theory in
like two days m um and Derek talks about
how like the class goes at the pace of
the slowest student and sometimes that's
you and sometimes that's someone else
and it changes based on every topic but
like averages out it's going to be quite
slow and so I've just always been
obsessed with this idea of you set the
pace right do you want this to take
multiple years sometimes it should and
sometimes it's the best for you or do
you want to get it done very quickly and
uh yeah that's probably a defining
factor in my life that's so good I was
just taking I was I I I feel like I had
so many kind of brain waves as you were
say as as you were saying that I think
this this idea of fixed work versus
fixed time is really important cuz if
you're if you're for example working at
Wendy's that's fixed time like you know
the work is always going to be there
it's not like if you work faster you can
then put your feet up I suspect right
but actually in most areas if I think of
every job that anyone that I know has or
if you're a if you're a student in
school or
university it feels like fixed time but
it's actually fixed work MH like when I
was working as a doctor I was you know
it was fixed time I was there from 8
till 6 but it was actually fixed work in
that if I could see the patients quickly
enough and to get everything done and
get them seen you know kind all that
stuff is done now I have some I've got
I've got some spare time now and where a
lot of my friends in that context were
using that spare time or just sort of
going at a leisurely Pace because they
know they have to be there until 6 p.m.
anyway and cuz why not it's a bit more
chill in their spare time they were like
scrolling Tik Tok or whatever the thing
was y whereas in my spare time I had a
side hustle and so I was like great I've
got an extra 20 minutes that I can like
you know grind and plan out a new
YouTube video or something like that oh
yeah similarly when I was at University
you know going through medical school I
was like okay I need to get this essay
done as quickly as possible so that I
can Tinker away on the business I was
building on the side or I'm designing a
landing page or making a s in WordPress
or stuff like that and it sounds like
that was your approach when you had the
day job as well like let me get this
[__] done as quickly as possible so that
I can and then use the rest of the 5
hours in the day while I'm being paid to
be here to actually learn and improve my
own skills and build my own stuff on the
side yeah and I I think that's so
important but most people don't have
that side thing and and many of them are
completely content with that right um I
have a brother who has a great career in
finance super happy with what he's doing
and and all that and and just has you
know I'm over here like constantly
starting all of these things and all
that he doesn't care about that I I
think we are both equally happy in life
uh and we just to have very different uh
different approaches um and but it's
just it's core to who I am that I'm
going to figure out okay what can I
learn what can I uh Implement and I
always try to find the overlap right
like when the iPad came out in 2010 four
the startup I was working for you know
we were designing iOS apps and so then
instead of like doing the minimum to
okay I designed the app at the time we
were designing in Photoshop that was
enough you know I handed it off that was
all the that was expected of me but then
I was saying hey why don't I learn how
to use interface Builder and xcode to be
able to implement the UI and let me take
that further and and learn how to
program so it wasn't like I was at my
job then doing something 100% different
um on the side I was saying okay how can
I do what's expected of me but take it
much further in a way that's going to
benefit me long term right like I
learned programming skills there that
were related to my job but not required
that I would not to use uh for years and
I sold you know 50,000 $75,000 worth of
iOS apps that I you know that were an
amazing side hustle thanks to the skills
that I took further yeah I think that's
a really good point around I think like
if like I'm I'm always mindful when I
when I do this episode speak speaking to
other entrepreneurs and stuff it can it
can seem as if it's like oh starting a
business is the only way to be happy but
it's really not like if someone
listening to this or watching this is
genuinely happy with their day job
fantastic you like the the the goal is
happiness contentment and meaning the
goal is not have a100 million business
and if you get happiness contentment
meaning from the day job which you
really enjoy and then you go home and do
stuff on the side and like have hobbies
and have work life balance and that that
is absolutely fantastic that is what
we're all trying to strive towards in
some way or another um but equally I
speak to a lot of my a lot of people I
know
who have the day job and they're not
content mhm they're like h feeling my
skills are being stifled I'm feeling
like I'm losing a bit of myself I used
to have all these interests when I was a
kid and then they got squashed out of me
by the education system etc etc capable
of more yeah and those people feel like
ah you know if only I could have an
extra 3K 5K month of passive income or
something like oh my God that would that
would be so liberating it would it would
buy my freedom whereas there are some
people in my team you as much as I
encourage people to have side hustles
you know Allison I had of cust of
success it's like I don't want to side
hustle I just want to chill I enjoy my
job I enjoy my team I you know I get
home from work and then and I hang out
with my friends and I go see musicals in
London and I'm like great she's like one
of the happiest people I
know but I think it's that thing around
like if you are complaining about your
situation then right starting a business
might actually be a reasonable
reasonable option if you do feel like
your job is not helping you reach your
potential when I think you brought up
something of you know even the 1,000 to
3,000 a month from a side hustle you're
going to get two huge things from that
first all of that money is on top of
what you already made and so you don't
have the same level of expenses that
that money has to pay and so it's
actually like substantially different um
you know as far as the impact that it
could make on you know your savings or
your vacation budget or whatever it is
that you value and then the other thing
is the skills that you learn like in
most companies if if say you're at least
10 to 20 people in the company um and
then this especially true as you get
into a 500 or a thousand person company
or Beyond right there's someone else who
knows how to do everything like
tangental to your job and so you're like
I do my thing in you know in in my case
right I do the design in Photoshop and I
can hand it all off there talented
people who will build a full app from
that and so you just don't have the same
level of growth and development because
you don't have to right your job is to
do your thing in your lane and the
people who say like no I want to know
more about everything that my work
touches and become obsessed with how
much can I learn right when you realize
that your brain is not the like as new
information comes in something else has
to go out right you're going to do the
digital Nomad thing right you're going
to be like okay I have you know these
two suitcases or something and someone's
going to be like here's this and you're
like what am I going to get rid of you
know to be able to make room for this
new thing that is not how your brain
works you're going to be able to
continue to take on new information so
um something that I'm I'm uh learning
how to be a pilot right now and so I'm
partway through uh flight lessons and
something that uh a friend pointed out
is like once you're a pilot you're a
pilot for life like your license is is
is for life now you need to like stay
current and and all of those things and
um do flight
reviews but I think of it the same way
with any of these skills like once
you're a designer you're a designer for
Life once you know like the principles
of great video and and production and
all that like you have that for life and
so I'm 33 and I'm thinking about like
okay what are these new skills that I
have forever and so when someone
presents me with the opportunity learn a
new skill then I'm like oh thank you
like like this is amazing what a gift
because I'm going to have that hopefully
for the next 60 years and uh yeah I I
think it's just a different mindset than
a lot of people have where you're just
like trying to fill the time or finish
the day man that's so good today's
episode is very kindly brought to you by
hu now I've personally been using heel
regularly since 2017 when I discovered
it in my 5ifth year of medical school
and if you've not heard of hu they're a
business that creates convenient
affordable meals in a a variety of
different forms but all of them are
nutritionally complete so they have the
perfect balance of nutrients carbs
fibers protein and fat and contain 26
vitamins and minerals and they've now
packaged some of their most popular
products into their best seller bundle
so you can try out all the heel products
and see which ones Vibe with you there
is Hu Black Edition which is my personal
favorite because it's really tasty and
it's high protein so 40 g of protein and
all you have to do is add water or milk
and you can shake it up and take it with
you wherever you want to go the bundle
also has heels instant meals which you
make in the microwave there's heel ready
to drink range which are pre-made shakes
in a bottle which is super handy and
I've actually grabbed a few of these in
the airport when I've been between
flights while traveling and finally
you'll also get some of the new heel
bars which I'm very excited to try out
myself plus if you're a new customer you
get a totally free heel t-shirt and a
Shaker and pot with your first order now
I wouldn't recommend having every meal
as heel because that would get a bit
much but it's a fantastic supplement to
a healthy balanced diet so often for me
I'll have heel either for breakfast or
for lunch where the alternative would be
to otherwise have a relatively unhealthy
breakfast and so heal is a great way to
make sure that you at least have the
basics covered when you are living a
hectic and or busy life he has very
kindly been a longtime supporter of the
podcast as well and I actually did an
interview with the founder of H Julian
Hearn which was a great episode and
that's in season one of the Deep dive
podcast so anyway thank you so much H
for sponsoring this episode this season
is Once Again being sponsored very
kindly by trading 212 now people ask me
all the time for investment advice uh
because they see that I've made money
and I've made videos talking about where
I'm investing that money the thing that
Warren Buffett and basically everyone
who's sensible in the space recommends
which is to invest in Broad stock market
market index funds which you can do
completely for free using trading 212
trading 212 is a fantastic app that lets
you invest in stocks and shares and
funds in a commission free fashion and
they've got a bunch of features which
are really helpful which is why I
personally use trading 212 to manage a
portion of my portfolio so firstly
they've got this great pies and auto
invest feature so if you're interested
in potentially getting into investing
what you can do is you can browse the
different pies that different people
have created on the platform so you
might get like a hedge fund Trader who's
gone onto the platform and has created a
pie of Investments having done a bunch
of research and stuff and that P might
be like I don't know 20% Apple 20% Tesla
10% this 10% that but it generally way
more complicated than that and you can
see the performance of that particular
pie of stocks and shares and funds and
then if you want to copy that pie into
your own account you can just copy and
paste it directly in and then you can
invest any amount of money and it will
automatically split it according to the
allocation in the P so if you wanted to
just play around with £100 and you were
like okay that P looks good it will
split out that 100 based on the
allocations of the P which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of1 so it's literally free money
so you might as well so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode as as much as I'm all about like
growth and skill development and stuff I
have encountered situations recently
where taking an opportunity would have
allowed me to build build new
skills so so for example one thing that
we've been toying with the idea for a
while and maybe we'll talk about this
when we talk about billion dollar
creators is can we build our own
productivity app right we've got
enormous distribution even if we have
feature parity with with an existing
productivity app we can make our own
to-do list and drive tons of traffic to
it and it would be great and and stuff
but then I'm thinking oh but
that would require either that would
either require me to hire a CTO or to
try and learn the skills to become a CTO
and figure out how to hire developers or
figure out how to work with an agency
and then our costs go up etc etc and I
know I would learn a lot in that process
of trying to build a consumer
productivity app and I know it would be
pretty
hard but there seems to be in my in my
mind this trade-off of like ah it's it's
it's too much effort like it's it it
would teach me a lot of new things but
it just feel feels kind of hard like
does that Vibe at all yeah well I think
it's the way that I think about setting
goals is around what am I going to learn
from this goal right so we have a goal
at conver growing to 100 million a year
in Revenue yeah uh we sit at 40 million
a year right now and so you know in my
head there's like the little uh I don't
do they do this in the UK like with
fundraising uh things they'll have like
a thermometer that they like color in
you know so I'm like okay we're 40% to
uh to goal
and it's not I don't set the goal
because I'm going to hit
self-actualization when Revenue like
tips over that additional digit what I
think of is what are the skills that I
have to learn to build something to that
level and so we talk about how you know
one of the best paths for you to um
build a business worth $100 million or
more is you know consumer productivity
app and we could set that out and that's
fantastic but if we break down and go
okay that's the goal
who do you have to become in order to
achieve that goal what skills do you
have to learn and if we write those out
and it's things that you talked about
right you have to get very good at
understanding uh user Behavior how to
work with developers how to hire you how
to scale a team like all of these other
things and so you list out all those
skills and if you're like yeah know I
those skills aren't interesting to me
that person right if we look at Future
Ali who has to have those SK s and be in
that if that life doesn't sound
interesting to you then great move on to
a different goal I think too often we
either set a goal uh without realizing
what's going to be required to achieve
it who we have to become to achieve it
or we go the other way and say like oh
this is what I'm trying to do I want to
get better at this one skill without a
goal in mind and so I think the overlap
of those two things clearly
understanding what's the goal and why
and then who do I have to become to
achieve it is what results in
you know something that you're really
really proud of and willing to work on
for long enough because if you're like
hey I have this idea for an app I'm
going to throw it together you know like
it should be live in three months and it
should have 100,000 users by the end of
the year and you know like all of this
stuff guess what it's going to not work
out that way like it's going to be 10
times harder than you thought take 10
times longer and if you're we're just
looking for like the neat way to use
your audience for distribution then
you're going to give up when it gets
hard but if you're like oh no this is
the goal this is the mission and I'm
very clear on who I have to become in
order to achieve that then you'll stick
with it when things get really hard
there's a journaling prompt I've started
using thinking about recently which is
because you know people say that um one
one way to figure out what you want is
ask yourself what would you do if you
knew you couldn't fail yep and I made a
list of that and productivity app was on
the list but then I asked myself what
would I do even if I knew that I would
fail and productivity apples was not on
that list okay uh but there were a
couple of other things of like even if I
knew that this would fail I would still
like to do the thing like I love the
idea of building a sort of hour one to
two hour long onean stage show which is
like a combination of like life advice
meets magic cuz I'm into magic and [__]
like hypnosis that kind of stuff that
would be cool and it would learn a lot
even if it fails right you'd be very
proud of that and product even if a
failure is like like a 100 people came
to watch it exactly yeah and like
writing a book it's like I even if not
many people buy the book as long as I've
written a book I'm proud of I'll be I'll
be happy with that whereas for the
productivity app I'm kind of like uh I
wouldn't do this unless I knew it was
going to be successful and if I knew and
if I knew it wasn't going to be
successful H it doesn't seem fun anymore
yeah and so in that case one that I love
that Clarity because it points to what
you're going to take away right most
people are saying this is worth doing if
I achieve the goal or if I achieve 80%
of the goal yeah and what you're saying
is this is worth doing even if I achieve
0% of the goal and I actually like the
true goal is the experience and what I
learn and I think that's how you can
find what's most aligned to the one
thing I would say is often people don't
know I mean it's corny right but you
don't know what you don't know and so
like for me in building the
company I've spent a lot of time getting
good at design and code and marketing
and all of that and I'm trying to get
good at building teams and setting goals
that keep people aligned and right it's
an entirely different skill to run a
company at you know 100 people and um
you know whatever 50 100 million revenue
and Beyond from there uh than it is you
know for me to be selling eBooks like I
was before and
so the shift that has been most helpful
for me is to fall in love with the
process of building and scaling a
company rather than to fall in love with
the theoretical destination and whatever
that might whatever that might buy me
and so then when I'm going through
something that's really really hard then
I'm like oh no this is this the growth
from this transition is what I signed up
for and what I said that that I want and
so this is the thing that will make the
difference and then the the last thing
that keeps me from getting too
discouraged in that is I like to write
out my problems that I've encountered
and so just sort of have a timeline of
them M and then to look and say how
would like current me deal with my past
problems right so for example the early
stages of Co right in March uh 2020 you
have no idea what's going on teams are
worried we were already a remote team
and so we didn't have that like shut
down the office um Dynamic but we had
both a crazy amount of growth from
people being like I guess I'll start an
online business and then also a huge
amount of cancellations from people
saying like well no one's traveling so
let me shut down my travel blog so I'm
not paying for all of this it was a very
very hectic time and it was it was
really stressful but now that I've been
through that and I feel like I'm three
years more developed as a leader I'm
like okay I think I can manage that just
fine right and there's plenty of other
things that I remember being very very
stressed out about and now I'm like oh
that like that's almost cute how simple
of a problem that was and so that helps
me stay grounded when I'm thinking about
the things that I'm encountering right
now that are so so stressful and I'm
like in two years from now how am I
going to look back on this problem and
my goal is that I look back on it and
say like yeah for for past me that was a
very challenging problem but current me
would be like okay that makes sense
we're on to like bigger harder problems
that we can handle with the same level
of stress and so I love using that
growth that's what one of the things in
journaling is just like what are the
hardest problems and so you'd be like
March 2020 you know how to lead a team
and navigate through Co right right um
June 2020 would be like all of the um
social justice protests and um black
lives matter and and what to do through
that right and you kind of just level up
all these things that uh that you
navigate even a simple right if you have
a the you build that that consumer
productivity app okay what happens when
it gets pulled from the app store for
the first time because of some random
thing right you know I've now had that
happen on four different apps at
different times right so you're like oh
this is how you do it this is you know
and how you navigate it and so but in
the moment that would be the most
stressful thing that you've probably
ever dealt with and so I love looking at
that growth and seeing the past progress
in the same way that if you're going to
the gym and you're like okay you know I
was doing this uh I don't know deadlift
or something and this
was insurmountable and now like that's
what you do for a warm-up set
yeah um so you're you're in the day job
you're making your 60k you're completing
the work in record time and alongside
you're learning how to build iOS apps
what happens next in in the journey yeah
I the first IOS app that I built to sell
was uh I called it one voice and uh my
sister-in-law was working with kids with
special needs like who had um non-verbal
autism and so they could think through
everything they wanted to say but really
struggled to to verbalize it and so
there's these uh devices that were like
ruggedized touchscreen PCS um that had
terrible battery life and cost an absurd
amount of money and uh and all of that
but they would use an app on it that had
synthesiz speech so they would select
tiles and then it would like build a a
sentence and then it would speak for you
um and so she was doing that and when
the iPad had come out um Hannah my
sister-in-law was like this should just
be an iPad app like but it's such a
niche uh
product and the money is all made in
Insurance paying for it and so like
these were priced at $7,000 because that
was exactly what Medicaid in the United
States would reimburse for it you know
and you're like all right I understand
how this
works um and so I ended up making this
iPad app that was the same thing right
and so you bought an iPad for whatever
$7 or $800 and you bought the app and
you know it naturally had fantastic
battery life and barely weighed anything
and all of that just because it was on
better Hardware um and so I ended up
building that app and uh selling a lot
of copies of it and then uh I want to
say the app probably made4 or $50,000
over uh maybe three years and that drove
a lot of my side hustle and then and you
built that while you were still working
yep at the day job sick that's cool yeah
we actually I went to the job paid for
me to go to uh like a developer Camp um
that was at the PayPal offices and San
Jose and they did like a hackathon and
so it was like oh you join team and you
know people had their different ideas
and you join the team code with them the
whole weekend and meet people and learn
a bunch of stuff and none of the ideas
seemed that interesting and I was there
with a a developer friend from from work
and uh so we you know I was like does
anything sound interesting to you to
join he's like no not really and so then
I was like well I have this idea for an
app like let's design and build it and
code away on it and so that weekend he
helped me with the initial version and I
like learn a lot and then maybe the next
few months uh you know I'd build more it
actually was the way that I learned to
code I always like to make something
specific like I'll do the the you know
100 level like let me just learn the
basics and then I'll get to the point
where I I have something specific that I
want to
make and I I code in every direction
until I get totally stuck and then I
would go to a
friend there's a few developer
co-workers and I would like go over to
their house on a Saturday morning and be
like okay I'm now stuck in these three
categories like and they'd be like okay
here's why right like I'm trying to do
something they're like do you know about
different types of numbers I'm like what
like okay we've got floats and integers
and you know like they're like computer
science 101 um but it was fun to to get
have someone help me get unstuck and
then I'd be off like coding more and
Googling and stack Overflow and
everything else and um but yeah I built
that app I built uh one that I called
commit which was a habit tracking app so
like along the like don't break the
chain idea uh that ended up being really
impactful I built a flash cards app um
that did delayed repetition
um and those are the three that like I
actually sold and got got traction with
to the point where when I quit my job uh
to do freelance iOS design I had I was
making about $3,000 a month on the App
Store from those three apps
wow how did how did it feel at the time
to be just getting 3K a month from like
ohing making money while you sleep
basically yeah it's absolutely fantastic
and because it was integrated right like
the apps that I built helped me get more
like demonstrate expertise which helped
me get more clients which helped me um
you know both pay for all my living
expenses and learn new things that went
into the apps that I built and so it was
this like you know virtuous cycle very
early on where I was like oh this is all
directly related um and I was just doing
what I wanted and and that was also the
first time that uh I was able to like
travel and not be tied to an office job
so that was a really good time nice uh
when was this 2011 2011 okay cool yeah
2011 to 2012 nice okay so you had your
so you've got the day job your learning
skills on the side building these iOS
apps as a side hustle you then quit the
day the day job and you become a a
freelance iOS designer design designer Y
what happened next when did the ebook St
to enter the the frame yeah so around
the time I'd come across a guy named
Chris Gilbo from Reading um I think he
written a guest post on Tim Ferris is
blog and it's one of those things I feel
like this doesn't quite happen as much
anymore maybe it still does where you
come across someone's work and then you
just like fall yeah just just everything
like and this was me with your podcast
and blog yeah about like 5 years ago I
love it um yeah where you just uncover
everything and so uh I started following
everything that Chris did and he had
this oh I remember like I read
everything and it was like oh he has a
book coming out oh he has a book tour
that he's doing for this book this the
book was called The Art of
non-conformity and then I was like wait
he has a book tour he's going to be in
boisee on Tuesday like and so then I
went to the the event and met him and
um but he talked a lot about building
audience and self-publishing uh he had
two ebooks that I really likeed that
were for free um the first one was
called a brief Guide to World Domination
Chris was always so good with naming
things you know I just love the ju toos
it's sort of like Mark Manson's right
the subtle art of not giving a [__] you
know you're like oh these
don't uh the ju's position within that
title works really well and so Chris
back in you know 2011 or something is
doing a brief Guide to World Domination
um and that was really fascinating and
then he did another one called 279 days
to overnight success that was about his
blogging journey and basically him going
from uh starting his audience to earning
a full-time living which he defined as
$60,000 a year I I think in the ebook he
has got like by the time he publishes it
he's gotten to like $65,000 a
year and he put them into like these
beautifully designed PDFs and
distributed them so a lot of what you're
seeing you know in authority and and all
of that is inspired by things I learned
from Chris and watched him
model and so he was following the
self-publishing path build an audience
self-publishing ebook and uh so then I
thought okay maybe I could do that but I
didn't think I could sell books on that
level and so I thought what I actually
want is more design clients and so I'm
going to write a book and self-publish
it on designing iOS apps um and then the
goal well I had two goals from it uh
first get a whole steady string of
clients right you want to hire the guy
who wrote the book on on
design um and then also if I can make
$10,000 in Revenue over like the
lifetime of the book that would be a
success I didn't want to do like the
true or the full like oh this um this
book is just a business card it doesn't
have to make any money like I think
that's a cop out right you should try
if you put time into making something
you should try to distribute it to as
many people as possible and uh make some
real money with
it so I ended up like building a landing
page writing tutorials driving traffic
from the tutorials to say like hey I'm
writing this book um sign up to get the
wait list built that email list on mail
jimp uh on launch day I had 798 people
uh on the wait
list and uh I ended up selling $12,000
worth of the book in the first day wow
and so I got hooked on a couple things
one I realized like forget freelance
design work like the goal was to get
clients I never took on another design
client after that right I just I was all
in on
self-publishing uh and then the second
thing is I just I became obsessed with
the world of like self- publishing and
like okay what what can I do with this
and what can I do with marketing and
like I was okay and at Mar like I knew
how to make a landing page I knew how to
do some of these things but then I was
like uh what can I do and really it was
like email marketing like I thought at
the time that uh you know Instagram and
Twitter and these other Facebook would
be driving most of the of the traffic
most of the conversions but it was email
to drive all of that and actually in
boisey where I live there's like this OG
internet marketer Crew That's there cuz
ClickBank and bodybuilding.com and a
bunch of these companies were all
founded in boisey and so you get these
people who have been around for a long
time talking to one friend
Ron uh about this and I was like email
is selling more copies like than every
other channel combined and he just looks
at me he's like yeah we've known that
since 2003 like what do you want a gold
star like I'm like discovering this
thing that's blowing my mind and he's
just like everybody knows that like I I
didn't and so that kind of the dove into
my love for self-publishing and
marketing and then particularly email
marketing and then actually this the day
after that I had been using my habits
app commit that i' had made to write a
th000 words a day and so it popped up
and said like are you going to write a
th000 words today and I was like no I
finished the book I published it and I
was like but it had like 84 days in a
row of a streak I was like uh okay I'll
write a I'll write a blog post about how
the launch went so I wrote that up
published it that drove some more sales
got people paying
from like a oh you know some random
designer can make money selling any book
maybe I could
too and then the next day the app did
what it does and it popped up again and
said are you g to write a thousand words
today and I was like what I wrote the
book I wrote all the launch emails I
wrote a blog post summarizing how the
launch went like what else would I
write and then I thought like I mean I
know web
design and specifically web software
design really well because that's what I
did for years so like okay let me write
a book about that let me follow a
similar habit or Sim similar pattern and
so then I wrote a book uh called
designing web
applications it didn't take that long to
write because I wrote a thousand words a
day and so 90 days later I published it
uh the email list was up to a couple
thousand people at that point end up
doing $26,000 in sales of that book in
the first in the first day nice 50,000
in the first
month something that I just realized
someone asked me this years ago and I
didn't have an answer for it uh but I
just made a little
connection of why I targeted One Day
sales because it's like okay why does
the first day of sales matter especially
because I have this big spike because I
would offer like a 20% off discount if
you bought the first day and then that
would go away and then there'd be sales
tapering off uh Chris Gilbo in one of
his articles talked about how he hit
$1,000 in sales in a single day from a
course launch and I think that always
stuck with me of like the one day thing
and I like designed my launches around a
single day number even though I think
probably the optimal launch would be
over the course of a week you know or
but it's interesting these little like
examples that stick with
you yeah so
I yeah always optimized for for a single
day number but the point is that I got
on this path of writing and launching
ebooks and just felt like I discovered
something absolutely incredible a couple
questions on this so I I I remember now
one of one of the early blog posts I
came across that you wrote well it
wasn't early for you it was early for me
discovering your stuff was when you'd
written for like an absurd number of
days in a row can you remember how many
that was the the chain got up to six uh
600 days in a row you wrote a thousand
words a day for 600 days in a row yeah
what the
[__] well first a thousand words is not
that much yeah it's not that much but
it's it it feels like feels like a lot I
mean it compound like on one hand so a
thousand words a day is probably two and
a half pages yeah right and I remember
Tim Ferris talking about this Chris
Gilbo talked about it the way Chris
Gilbo phrased it he had this like it's
really easy to what did he say it's
really easy to write a book every year
write 50 blog posts in another 50 guest
posts uh what else like a couple long
form writing projects maybe some
magazine articles he like just lists out
all the stuff he's like it's really easy
to do that in a single year everyone's
like what it takes years to write a book
it takes years to do all that
he's like if you just write a thousand
words a day and we talk about like
habits compounding over time and you
know these small things adding up but
600,000 words is an insane amount of
content that's absolutely insane and I
mean that that one habit built my entire
career right because that's a whole lot
of email newsletters that's it turned
into three self-published books cuz
later I wrote Authority actually this
time period from September September M
2012 I published the app design handbook
December 2012 I published designing web
applications and then April 2013 so like
in this like seven-month period uh I I
published Authority and so I wrote three
books in that period of time because I
was just churning out content um grew
the email list right that one habit just
was was absolutely insane for me this
episode is sponsored by kajabi and
they've actually got something really
valuable for all of our Deep dive
listeners now if you haven't heard of
kabi it's basically a platform that
helps creators diversify their revenue
with courses and membership sites and
communities and podcasts and coaching
tools so it's one of the best places for
creators and entrepreneurs to build a
sustainable business we started using
kajabi earlier this year and as soon as
we started using it we were like oh my
God why haven't we been using this
product for the last 3 years it's got
everything you'd possibly need for
running an online course or hosting an
online community or building an online
coaching business and it essentially
makes it really easy to run your entire
online business from payments to
marketing tools to analytics kajabi has
everything that we creators need all in
one place and actually you don't
necessarily need a huge audience to
generate a sustainable income a Creator
on kajabi can for example make $100,000
by converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to a $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out over
$6 billion doar to creators that billion
with a be and over a thousand creators
have become millionaires through
products on the platform now back in May
2023 I did a keynote at a kajabi in real
life kajabi Heroes Event in Austin Texas
and in that keynote I talked about the
exact steps that I use to grow my
business from Zer to over $2.5 million
per year from course Revenue alone now
people paid for the pretty expensive
tickets to watch this keynote at the
kajabi hero live event but as an
exclusive deal for deep dive listeners
kajabi have very kindly offered to
provide the recording of that keynote
completely for free to anyone who
listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that Keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode what did it look like like
practically speaking okay so I'll give
you some context um our mutual friend
sha McCabe had a course somewhere about
writing in ulyses yeah the writing app
and I watched that course many years ago
and I was like I want to write th words
a day this was when I discovered your
stuff I did it for like 3 days and then
I I I dropped off and like two months
ago I rediscovered ulyses on my iPad and
I set the the target like I I put all of
the folders into one folder so I could
track that folder and I set a target of
1 th000 Words a day and when I do write
and I'm typing away I find myself
effortlessly hitting a thousand because
it's actually not that many words and
when I write my newsletter I'm like oh
[__] this was 2,000 words better cut
some of it down and I'm curious what did
for you what did this process of a th
words a day look like what what app were
you using where were you writing how did
you figure out what you were going to
write about where did the inspiration
each day come from how did that work
well it was weirdly like the requirement
was that it had the app I wrote in had
to have really good word tracking
because that was the your word count um
and so I used scrier because that was
the app at the time that was the best at
having like
individual uh Pages almost yeah but then
would be summarized well um like could
be compiled total and so scrier let you
set a goal like hey I want this book to
be 35,000 words and it would tell you
both your Daily Progress and your total
progress against that across all of the
like Pages down down s side so you can
organize it and categorize the whole
thing um so I wrote in scrier I
uh would if I when I was writing a book
I would write an outline for it and then
I would take that outline and make
folders and empty pages for each title
within it and I
would put an asterisk at the beginning
of the title if I like hadn't written
anything meaningful for it so I would
kind of just skip around and be like Oh
click on this I don't have anything to
say about that today click on this oh
here's a few notes that I would add to
it and like oh there was that article
right so I'm just kind of compiling
things then I'd find one I was like huh
I have something to say on this and I
would like click in and and write a
whole bunch um as much as I could on
that one topic and then um keep going
from there and so that it was kind of
sporadic in that sense yeah but um you
know actually built out a full book and
then I have another section for my
marketing copy right like another folder
at the very end because I knew I had to
write launch emails and landing pages
and all that and like that absolutely
counts towardes my thousand words for
the day everything counts and there'
even be some days like I don't like
editing and so I would count I was like
okay this is an
editing hour and that to me was
equivalent to a th000 words you know so
I'm like I'm going to force myself to
edit and chop down and all of that and
I'm going to get credit for my day worth
of writing um the other thing that I
would do is try to make it easy just in
Apple notes to like throw out ideas of
like oh yeah okay this is what I should
write about later um and it's a classic
writing uh
technique but end oh who talked about
this someone famous end in the middle of
the sentence um it was someone famous
yeah I've cited them in my book but I
can't remember who it was yeah was it
like Hemingway or something yeah
something like that Twain Hemingway or
yeah uh Einstein or Lincoln or whoever
was I'm just
kidding gandi no
uh and so I would just do all of those
uh classic things and usually when I
would sit down and have nothing nothing
to write about like if you just force
yourself to write for like and you get
through that first 10 minutes then it's
totally fine the other one is Seth Goden
has a quote where
um basically about writing you should
write like you talk yeah cuz no one you
you don't have talkers
right that you know if you're just
trying to talk to yourself and so using
now transcription stuff is really good
and so like just talk on the topic um
I'll do that when I'm in the car I'll
just start a voice memo and then be like
okay what do I have to say about
audience bu you know like whatever the
topic is and then I'm like uh okay then
what about this and here's the story and
it's all like nonsense but then you
transcribe it and you go through like
okay that's a whole thing to write on so
it's this and um and then that you know
you rewrite write it and you get the
stories and the structure and and all of
that but it's it's pretty
straightforward you just have to force
yourself to do it but the the Habit
compounds in ridiculous way this is good
[__] I'm I'm feeling so inspired right
now I feel like if I if I could if I
actually sat down and wrote a thousand
words per day that would be the single
thing that would drive me most towards
like literally every single goal that
I'm working on right and even goals that
I don't even know I have right now
because they're all around content
sharing my thoughts content creation
writing making
videos well getting clear on all of
these all of these ideas right something
we talked about these Flagship essays
that I like to work on I have three um
lers of wealth creation billion dollar
Creator and then the Creator flywheels
these are all on things that I generally
know to be true or like I'm like yeah
this is how wealth is built but I can't
quite explain it and so through writing
I get obsessive about how do you explain
this why why does this work in a certain
way you know and then it turns into this
thing to get to where I understand the
concepts well enough that I can truly
teach it and that's what I what I love
with writing is finding all the things
that you intuitively know to be true or
observe in the world and then someone's
like okay why is that you're like
uh it it just is you know and and that
really takes you into like writing
forces you to unpack that and then one
of my mantras in life is teach
everything you know because that turns
into or we have this idea that only
experts can teach and the the main
principle behind my book Authority is
that we
don't uh people don't teach because
they're experts we perceive them as
experts because they teach right it's
chicken and egg and we have it backwards
um and so in that if you step into a
world where you're like okay I'm just
going to teach what I learned
today then you build that habit you
write it down and someone's like okay
I'm you know following this web designer
who is brand new but they're on a
journey to get a a job at you know web
design agency and they're just every day
they're sharing and teaching what they
learned and they're doing it from a
beginner's mindset and I you can learn
way more from that person if you're
following like two steps behind them
than following the super Advanced expert
who forgot how like who cannot relate in
any way to the problems that a absolute
beginner is facing uh
I thought about that when learning
learning to code in Ruby which is what
conet has written
and I really struggled to install Ruby
but all the tutorials were like why
would you you know they all assumed that
that was done right and then I came
across someone who was a beginner who
had said like okay I just got this done
here are the all the roadblocks I
thought not like the ideal path but this
is what I actually ran into and how I
solved it and I was learning from
someone who was like two steps ahead of
me and they actually gave me the answers
and I followed them uh their content for
a long time so anyway writing teaching
it all comes back to that it's all the
same stuff yeah teach everything you
know um the the book show your work by
Austin Clon was a big um that was the
thing that made me start my first blog
in like 2016 yeah cuz I've been toying
with the idea of like I really want to
have a personal blog but I was like
blocked by like oh I don't know anything
why would follow me etc etc show your
work was just like share what you're
working on and at the time I'd you know
been four years into building this
medical school admissions company and
website design and I was like I mean I
have learned some stuff along the way
about like how I started the business
and all this stuff I like great I had to
do blog post about that and that was the
precursor to the YouTube channel that
happened a year later so I'm all about
teach everything you know I love it um
yeah my I used to have three mantras on
my wall and by the way I love looking at
your books because you have show your
work uh in the Austin Cleon section of
of your bookshelf um but I I had these
three posters on my wall in like my
first real home office
and there were the three mantras of
create every day teach everything you
know and work in public and that was
like my equivalent of of show your work
and then the posters I should bring them
back it's been years since uh I've done
it but up in the like kind of small up
in the corner they say the secret to
growing your audience is to and then the
big thing is work in public create every
day teach everything you know what do
what do you mean by work in public well
it's the same idea of showing your work
right like what is the thing that you
learned today that you could share with
other people or so many people say like
okay I well I created my I wrote my
ebook right I published and launched it
and someone's like oh sweet I bought the
ebook from you I bought um I'm learning
app design from you all that that's
super
useful but most people don't take the
next step and write the blog post about
like here's how I did the launch here's
how much money it made and everything
else which is actually like the least
difficult part you know everything else
doing the thing was way harder than
explaining how you did the thing and how
it went and so working public in that
case was public the blog post I
published the day after I wrote the AP
handbook that said like okay it made you
know 12 Grand uh here's a launch
sequence here's what drove
sales some of the there was some overlap
right some people
who I wrote the some people who were
designers wanting to learn for the app
like or some people wanted to learn app
design were the same people who wanted
to read like about how the launch went
there was definitely overlap not not
100% overlap but there's some but then
it brought in other people who wanted to
learn about self-publishing who were
like oh this is Possible Oh and then I
know someone who wants app design right
and so it was Marketing in a sense even
though it wasn't like architected from
the beginning to be great marketing but
I think that process all the way along
of uh teach everything you know work in
public those are the things that make a
big difference when I started to convert
kit I really embodied that work in
public idea when I said hey I'm going to
build a software company I'm going to do
it um you know only with $5,000 of my
money it's going to be sold or like
funded by customers and my goal is to
get to 5,000 a month in recurring
Revenue within six months and I called
that the web app Challenge and I blogged
every uh week about here's how I chose a
name here's how I hired a developer
here's the problem that facing okay
pre-sales are ready to go who wants to
buy you know like and I shared all of
that and I think it made a huge
difference because people were like oh
here's someone going on a journey that I
want to follow right unfolding in real
time so not only did I get more
attention but I also got a lot of very
like talented experienced Founders
saying like hey if you ever need help
with anything like give me a call so um
Amy Hoy did a deep dive with me on
copyrighting for the landing page which
I then turned into a blog post right
it's like here's what I wrote here's how
Amy and I did it all I think I even
included the recording of the Skype call
um that we had done and like here's how
we came to the landing page and like all
these Concepts and and everything and I
was just sharing what I learned every
week um and sharing that journey and
that has been core to everything can bre
it like even today we have a real-time
dashboard that shares all the revenue
metrics for convertkit um that anyone
can look at right that that's working in
public
one thing that I was thinking about as
you were saying this I'm like writing is
the key um if I could do this thousand
words a day that would you know I'm I'm
all about teaching everything I know and
creating every day and working public
all that sound all that stuff is amazing
fully fully Vibe with that but whenever
I sit down to write so so for example we
did our book launch and there's a lot
that I have in my head that I'd love to
share about like how things went and how
we're tracking metrics and all this all
this kind of stuff but then I'm thinking
it's it's so Niche it's like I could be
making a video called 10 productivity
tips instead which would get like a
zillion more views than like a blog post
that's going deep on this thing that
I've learned that I would love to share
but it's just like if I'm going to spend
time on quote content creation I should
spend that time on content creation that
benefits the YouTube channel which is
massively leveraged compared to a blog
post any any thoughts on this well so uh
I've heard Nick Huber talk about the way
he thinks about on Twitter at different
stages of the funnel right so his
business um is or he now has a whole
bunch of businesses all around real
estate yeah right and self storage and
all that but what he was primarily
thinking about is there's some tweets
that are more General he takes like a um
antagonistic approach to Twitter right
he's uh trying to get some level of
outrage or uh agreement or that sort of
thing um but so he'll have these top of
funnel tweets that are about life and
work and family and and these other
things that will really spread and then
further down you know the middle of the
funnel he's thinking about um okay what
can I share about business um you know
lessons learned that are broadly
applicable but it's people who care um
from here and then the bottom of the
funnel he'll share like these I I've
learned a lot about like real estate tax
depreciation and all of this stuff from
these really in-depth detailed threads
that
get read by the right people right he's
putting out content that I mean I've
been running a business for a decade and
uh I didn't know a bunch of these things
and so he's
going way down the funnel and writing
these very Niche things and he's not
worried about that attracting at the top
of the funnel and so he's he's going
through and saying okay what do I do at
each stage of the funnel and because the
funnel ultimately for him at the time
that he was saying This was um like like
getting investors limited partners for
his real estate investing fund um now he
has a whole bunch of other businesses as
well uh but getting people who know that
he knows this stuff inside and out they
want to hire one of his companies to
help with one of these services like
that is insanely valuable but it takes
these people knowing that he exists and
so that's the approach that he takes of
some's this should get millions of views
this should get tens of thousands of
views and then this Niche cont if it
gets a thousand views from the right
people that's insanely valuable that's
one way to think about it the other way
is I got to write a thousand words today
what is interesting to me to write
down like what would be fun if I've been
weirdly obsessive about like a book
launch and how it all went great right
about that we're just trying to check
the box that we did the writing the
writing doesn't have to be the highest
quality or the most valuable because
it's also a little bit arrogant to know
that or to think that you're going to
create what you create today is the best
possible content that you could create
we're not trying to create the best
content we're just trying to create
consistently and then we'll let like the
future figure out what is actually worth
paying attention to and especially
because things are going to be pieced
together from 10 different sources and
you never know what your team's going to
be like oh this thing it's going to be
super valuable or say book number two
comes out right and you're like
shoot what what does make a good book
launch I don't know I wish I'd written
that down when I was right in the middle
of it we run team Retreats at convertkit
and we've run oh 10 of them now
something like that twice a year every
year and the thing that drives me crazy
is when I make a a small mistake on a
team Retreat of something that I got
right in a previous Retreat it could be
a transition it could be how we set up
um uh like for an all team meeting some
of those so I have a giant sop and
playbook for what makes a great team
Retreat that does two things for me I
don't repeat the same mistakes and then
two when I bring someone else in and
they're like how do we run team Retreats
I'm like there you go right so if you
launch or if you write this book launch
article yeah I'm going to read it and
absolutely love it and there's going to
be you know business audience nerds on
our level who are like thank you for
writing this I learned so much I you
know I'm plucking this other thing and
bunch of people just won't care but then
even think book number two team member
comes along and you're like here's how
we do book launches and you're not
sitting down and explaining it to them
for an hour because you disconnected
your knowledge from your time and so I
think it's hugely valuable to write and
uh when you write a thousand words a day
you're you're producing so much content
that great write the 10 productivity
apps you video script tomorrow that's a
great point I love I love both of those
approaches um what is interesting to me
about this I think yeah one thing I've
been thinking about a lot
is I'm sure you have the problem as well
but feeling feeling over scheduled like
there's always just random [__] in my
calendar where I'm like the key thing
that I actually care about is to be able
to learn and synthesize and share and
write and make videos because that's
like my jam and I'm finding myself doing
all this other stuff that does not
involve doing those
things and I realized recently like even
just like flying somewhere to give a
talk is taking time away from like it's
not really the core thing I care about
the core thing I care about is to be
able to write stuff then put it put out
there on the internet and so because my
writing time is so squeezed I'm I'm I'm
now thinking Roi for every single thing
that I I write and that takes me into
this territory of like well I could
write about topics a to zed that I'm
interested in but actually instead I'll
write about topic y that I don't really
care about but I know it's going to get
the views because I only have 20 minutes
to day to do any sort of writing at all
and the views of what drivve the
business and the business and supports
the team salary and it's just becomes
this thing where I've created a prison
for myself right through over scheduling
in the calendar for [__] that I don't
actually fundamentally care about that
stops me from doing the thing I actually
care about then I would I would love to
do and then the commercial incentives
are all like [__] all this up as well
any thoughts how do
I yeah yeah what was on my mind as you
were saying that is some of my favorite
things that I've written have been when
I don't fully understand it or don't
quite know how to articulate it yet and
I've pursued input from other
people right like the latter's wealth
creation article uh has a lot of input
from James clear on it because I was
like here's this thing that I'm trying
to articulate and we were at a friend's
uh bachelor party for for a weekend you
know and it's a whole bunch of business
friends and so we're all like nerding
out on the essays that we're writing and
that kind of thing um different vibe
than Maybe traditional Bach I was going
to say that sounds like a great bachor
party yeah that is exactly the kind of
bachelor party that I'm into um but
we're talking about these things
and he he's just asking really good
questions and filling in examples he's
like well why is that why like how else
how could we visually describe that um
and that pursuit of an idea with someone
else I think is really interesting so as
you're technically like oh I'm going off
to like deliver this talk and it's not
furthering my like writing and and ideas
and learning goals my first thought is
well who else is going to be there who
would you love to not just catch up over
over coffee coffee but like say hey
here's you know I'm nerding out on
Flywheels for creators like you want to
grab coffee and talk about that for an
hour right because I'm trying to like
this essay doesn't quite work and um
that kind of thing is really really
interesting so I would try to combine
that and then I think broadly the point
that you're making of like what is the
ultimate engine that drives your
business
and how do you spend your time there and
you're saying like writing an idea
generation is the ultimate thing yeah
and so make sure that that is the the
core thing on your
calendar because ultimately if you stop
making YouTube videos if you stop stop
sharing ideas with your newsletter yeah
the rest of the business start
everything else dies yeah yeah it it to
be clear it has so much momentum that it
will it'll take a while for it to die
but it'll still die but it will
absolutely should keep paying our
convert kit monthly yeah exactly Point
like wait this isn't making as much
money as it every time we look at a
software Bill I'm just like okay yeah
yeah like 40% of it is convert kit like
fair enough we make way more money from
convert kit than we spent so y it's
totally fine um let's go think about
it just it just comes down a th words a
day a th000 words a day a thousand words
a day would literally change my life
yeah it's crazy a thousand words a day
would change the life of anyone
listening to this if they've gone an
hour and 18 minutes into this
podcast if you actually listening to
this you actually write 1,000 wordss per
day you just just damn you know so even
saying that right I did it for 600 days
in a row uh I actually ended up getting
shingles after that and so that's
sometimes people ask like well why
aren't you at like 1,200 days in a row
now it's like well I ended up getting
really sick and took me like six months
to recover and all that but I guess the
way to put it is it is simple but not
easy M and so yes writing a thousand
words a day will absolutely change your
life and that is a very simple thing but
it is not easy to do and you have to
design your day and your week around
that habit and that has to become one of
the non-negotiables and that's something
that honestly I've struggled with right
as I go back and forth between you know
building a team and scaling and all of
that I know that all of my goals would
be furthered by writing a thousand words
a day and I still write fairly
sporadically right now like I haven't
rebuilt that M and I think it's because
we say things to ourselves like ah this
should be easy and because we're
conflating simple and easy it is very
simple and it is not at all easy and so
if you get clear with yourself that like
okay I am setting out to do something
that is in fact very difficult and I
have to design my day around and my week
around making sure that this can happen
and this has to become my number one
priority in my business then at that
point you can actually make it happen
but if you're like ah this this will be
really easy I'll just knock it out and
then move on uh then you'll get to the
point where you can't build up any
meaningful streak and you won't get the
results from it any other tips any
mistakes you made along the 600 day
thing that you know I I feel like I feel
like I want to commit to that okay I'm I
am going to commit to this okay it's
writing a th words a day and I want to
get ahead of any kind of what are some
some obstacles I might run into and also
are you doing this on weekends as well
and yeah I did it seven days a week okay
right like if it's if it's that
important to you yeah the ideas is flow
seven days a week why not yeah exactly
um the first thing I would say is when
you run out of ideas a lot of people
worry that they're going to run out of
ideas and so they say like oh I might as
well not start generally what I find is
the more that you write the more that
you have to say because you find these
threads and you uh unravel
them the next thing is if you even with
that if you're still running out of
ideas think about things
that think about the content that you're
going to consume that's going to help
you uh find new
ideas so like if you get out of your
usual podcasts Y and start to listen to
other things right or the business
biographies or and you have these
prompts right you're like okay what
would uh you know if you're reading like
John D rockefeller's biography you're
like what would Rockefeller do if he ran
convertkit you know you're like oh
interesting well he probably have all
these back door deals and he's probably
acquiring other companies and you know
like oh blah somehow he creates a
monopoly and I don't know how it works
but you know it's a fun exercise right
you can have these prompts to dive into
but like I uh listen to Ryan Holliday on
jao willink's podcast um I don't
normally listen to jao's podcast but I
love Ryan's work and so I was like great
listen to this and it was a really
interesting take but Ryan said this
thing about
um he was talking about how Tim Ferris
in the early days of like audible really
getting traction started buying up the
the audio rights to a bunch of books cuz
you had this weird moment in time where
audible was getting traction and
Publishers did not value audio rights so
like Josh Kaufman who wrote the personal
NBA sold the publishing rights to his
book as you normally
do uh the publisher didn't want the
audio right so then they sold it to
somebody else and then it kind of
bounced around and then they were going
like he he was like I don't like this
and so he asked can I buy them back
until for like $10,000 or something he
bought back the audio rights the
personal NBA
uh published it himself through audible
audible had this crazy distribution
thing where like the more copies you
sold the higher percentage you got of
every copy sold and it ended up it got
to the point that at one point Josh was
making like $50 to $60,000 a month uh
off of exclusively the audio version of
the personal NBA nice Tim Ferris
understood this and started going around
buying the audio rights to any book
where the audio rights weren't valued so
uh you have the obstacles the way on
your shelf uh Tim Ferris owns the audio
rights to the obstacles way um and he
did this for a whole bunch of books yeah
and for like the Sia letters one of the
sto letters the one yeah um yeah so he
he's done it for really a lot because
there was this moment in time where
audio writs were radically undervalued
for um what they
got and so it made me think like
listening to that episode one I had been
around like I knew Tim and I knew Ryan
back then and so I remember talking to
like I remember hearing that and seeing
it all
unfold um but what it made me think of
is the phrase of like who's playing
chess when other people are playing
checkers and now that's turned into a
prompt for me of like okay where where
in my business am I playing checkers
when I should be playing chess and then
what other like stories can I share on
my podcast or or other things where uh
someone is operating at that level and
like I wouldn't like that is now a a
consistent thing in my journal that
phrase what would it look like to play
chess here you know who's playing chess
when others are playing checkers um and
I only got that because I listen to a
podcast outside of my normal uh like my
normal flow so when you're running out
of ideas um I guess two things on that
when you're running out of ideas of what
to write about switch up where you're
consuming information and then the
second thing is try to have these
consistent prompts that you come back to
that lead you to interesting places and
so two of mine are what would this
person do if like to tackle this problem
and then another is you know what would
it look like to play chess rather than
Checkers and if you end up with a stable
of like 15 or 20 of those then you can
go like problem or story and then prompt
and that will uh result in some
interesting thoughts some of which
hopefully will be worth
publishing um so you write a th000 words
a day but presumably you don't publish a
th000 words per day what does the yeah
what does the publishing segment look
like I I mean it's entirely uh up to you
you know I would just pick something and
stick with it I think publishing a
newsletter once a week and then um or an
essay sometimes newsletters are are a
little too low quality and I'd rather
people focus on like Flagship content I
struggle with that back and forth of
like staying consistent versus being
really really high quality
um I would just say pick a frequency and
stick with it
uh and it has to
be uh you want it to be at a point where
you're
not too frequent so that you can't hit
your Quality Bar yeah right some people
are like I'm going to write every single
day and then I'm like well you're not
Seth Goden you know you don't have that
like level of input of ideas and and all
of that so I think once a week is a good
consistent Cadence it forces you to stay
on topic and explore M um but then you
need something that you're really
pursuing right like uh some thread that
you're trying to pull on and unwind or
like a book that you're writing or or
like a meaningful project um otherwise
it it it'll fizzle out um so I've got
about four different book ideas that I
want to sort of pursue me too and I love
the idea of I was speaking to Mo Gat
about this who wrote soul for happy and
he he has about six different book ideas
and he says each day he does 2,000 words
a day he said I just pick whichever one
takes my fancy and I just T her away at
it do you do something similar where
you're like would you recommend that or
do you think it's it's helpful to have
just one thing that you're working
towards I think no matter what you do
it's important to have a way to capture
the ideas yeah that are sparked CU
sometimes like I have four different
book ideas I think and they sort of
overlap like is it this book is it that
book and you know what order should they
be published in and so the the biggest
thing is get theide IDE down on paper
and then you know either edit it
yourself or hire an editor someone else
will come along and be like oh no no no
this story is actually the thing that
we're going to use here we're going to
flip the whole thing around um that's
something like the order of the lads of
wealth creation article is very
different after James got his hands on
it was like no no no the like read the
whole thing you know but like let's uh
let's represent it like
this so I would be in the camp of just
right if that's what works for you
unless you're so scattered that it's not
working for you and then like force
yourself to to stay consistent but
otherwise like as you're writing one
thing make sure that like the documents
and the structure for the other thing
exists so you can be like oh this does
belong over here and you have a place to
put it and so it's not not lost or
wasted sick this is so good okay I'm
going to commit to this thousand words
per day that's that's the thing that is
the one um oh one other you are asking
for tips one other thing
is there are days that you can't for
whatever reason or shouldn't write a
thousand words right where you know it's
like okay I'm going to
go I don't know like with my uh partner
I'm off to go do this thing I'm going to
be entirely focused on time with them or
whatever and so people like what do you
do it's like oh just write more on the
bookends you know build up and be like
hey uh you know for this holiday weekend
I'm not going to write and so I guess
for the preceding week I need to write,
1500 words a day to get ahead nice and
and plan ahead like that and then also
look at your calendar and say like oh
it's going to be really hard to hit to
like to write on these days because of
whatever is happening and so I'm going
to make a plan for it right now
ultimately like you know I'm going to
get up earlier that day I'm going to uh
write in advance you know any of those
things and there were days that I
like forgot to write and instead of
being like Oh I broke the chain and all
of that and getting upset about it I
would just write double the next
[Music]
day yeah so like the the goal is 600,000
words in 600 days not you know not
literally a th000 words a day yeah okay
that's nice yeah because it gives you
the flexibility while also being able to
maintain the chain as it work it also
helps you think of it like a job where
it's not day by day it's like the the
big picture you know if it was like hey
I have to keep this Factory moving all
the time like with this level of output
you know but we want to take this week
vacation no problem just increase the
output by 50% for the preceding week or
two weeks yeah and you're good to go
easy so good simple not easy simple not
exactly yeah simple not easy um what do
you what are your thoughts on a personal
blog broadly and I ask
because so I like your website I like
Nathan bar.com it's it feels personal
it's good
vibes I'm unsure what to do with mine
my website
al.com uh it started off as a bit of a
personal blog it's now morphed into like
well this is good Legion for the
business and so we should get ghost
writers to write a [__] ton of articles
about how to grow on YouTube because
then that links to our YouTube of course
but then it sort of loses the charm of
like a personal blog and I like the
personal blog from an artistic sense
even though it may not make sense may
make less sense from a commercial sense
right I wonder what yeah do you have any
thoughts on this I don't have that exact
problem because I have convertkit and
Nathan berry.com fairly separate you
know they they is more of a publication
like they and it's clear that other
people are writing you know the vast
majority of that content
um now if you're trying to split it and
it's like okay you know one one thing be
like oh we'll spin out another site it's
like well but then I'm gonna have to
build domain Authority for that new site
and you're like ah don't do that from an
SEO perspective I would think of of it
like maybe you have these like
Flagship
um guides m that
are really going deep on and going to
rank very very well
for you know how to grow a YouTube
channel these
these high intent Search terms that are
going to be worth a lot of money to you
yes right this will turn into a $500
course purchase this will turn into you
know CU someone's trying to trying to do
that and I'd build those funnels really
carefully and then like I wouldn't do
the ghostwritten
um oneoff random things to rank because
I think Google rewards the flagship
articles much more yeah yet tons of
ghost writing help on those right like
make them amazing yeah it should be the
brain dump of your ideas and then have a
great editor like really go through it
so this is something that you're really
you know really proud of and can link to
and keep updated for years
yeah but I would keep the personal stuff
going I I think that's something that's
missing from the internet right now is
like the Classic this is what I'm
thinking about and I'm just following
that I wish I did it more um I do it a
decent amount in my newsletter but
um yeah like something I'm trying to do
is like scale it back just just like one
notch on the level of Polish so that not
everything has to be a fantastic essay
or something else like I want that more
raw feeling and less marketed but that's
just because that's what I want to exist
on on the internet yeah
same like I I really like discovering a
personal blog M and it's so nice
um yeah one thing one thing I I I like
less about yours is the fact that your
podcast BL I know me too it drives me
crazy and I'm just like oh I just want
to read the Nathan Barry like archives I
don't want to 078 interview with it's
like I would love for that to be
separate there's a bunch of those things
I'm like uh and I have the same issue
with mine it's like latest articles it's
like there all podcast episodes I'm like
oh it's not it's not it's not the vibe
yeah and it it's like what I want which
of course I have people on the team so I
could just I just pay to do actually
it's kind of a weird thing I have a lot
of people on the conver team and I don't
really have people on the on team Nathan
and so you end up with this like oh you
know they make like it's the WordPress
install is in like the convertkit wp
engine server and so they make sure it's
updated and all that but it's like yeah
they have other things uh but yeah I
want the site to like be like these are
the flagship essays these are the recent
random usings you know I want it to be
the kind of site that it's easy to get
lost in where you just like go down the
rabbit hole and binge it all and um but
yeah it's I I would definitely what I
want more people to write about is what
they're most interested in and then like
the behind the scenes the content like I
can get the 10 productivity app tips a
handful of different places yeah but
like I want to read the like obsessive
book launch things or like here's how
like I loved tho Forte's content about
how he built out his garage Studio you
know and it's not like in theory this is
how you should do it it's like this is
what I actually did um and so I just
love that like the the show your work
kind of things um because I want to
follow I want to follow the person more
than I want to follow the advice yeah
yeah I think one of
the one of the issues and I I think
maybe this sort of the niba funnel that
you mentioned solves this but one of the
issues is when and I I guess every media
outlet has this issue where it is the
the buzz feedy 10 productivity apps
stuff that will get the clicks and get
the views from a mainstream audience mhm
even though that's the stuff that's just
like objectively less
interesting yeah and the more
interesting stuff it does not get those
views but maybe and I like I like the
way you phrased it sort of views from I
guess quote the right people if you're
trying to attract audience of like if I
want people like you to read my blog
someone like you is not going to read my
article about 10 productivity hacks like
why would you but if I said if it was a
an in-depth look at how my book launch
went and like the numbers behind it and
the screenshots and how we tracked
things and fathom and then the graphs
and [__] like you would read that and
you're the sort of person that I would
like to be part of my newsletter because
it's like you're bar it's like yeah it's
like the the people who are executing at
a high
level will read Niche stuff not whereas
the there just this sort of separation
of like the mainstream and it sounds
weird to kind of say this because I
don't want I don't want people listening
to this to think that I'm ungrateful for
the AUD audience and stuff but it is
just like someone like you or someone
like Tim Ferris would read a very
different blog post right compared to a
random person in the audience who
doesn't have their own business for
example well and the great thing is that
you can segment audiences and I think
that people don't do that enough right
I've written a lot about how to earn a
full-time living as a content creator
it's a topic I'm very passionate
about at some point I feel like I've
written enough about that and there's
enough written on the internet you know
by the like 0 to 6,000 or 0 to
100,000 the Gap that I felt like was
there in the market it's like okay
you've done that you now have if you
understood audience building and
leverage and marketing and everything
else enough to get to 100,000 a year in
Revenue I bet with the right steps you
get to 500,000 a year and what I wanted
to write about is okay at what happens
now you're now making $500,000 a year
more than you ever thought possible more
than anyone else in your family more
than you know all of these things what
do you do because there's real problems
that come with that
and I wanted to write about that topic
but I
knew that's not what you write about to
a 50,000 person 30,000 person email list
yeah and so what I did is said okay I'm
going to create my own paid newsletter
it's only paid so that there's a little
bit of a barrier to get into it I don't
really care about the money from it but
uh I called it my secret money
newsletter and I said it's 100 bucks one
time to get on the list rather than
committing to like writing every single
week I made an an email course and so I
started it when I had like six emails
written out and you'd get one every
Friday Y and then whenever I felt
inspired I'd add another one it's now 17
emails long and people just get all the
emails and they wait at the end until I
added another one and then it'll be 18
and so so on from there but it let me
write to a different audience without
the caveats because I just said like
look if you're making less than 200,000
a year this is not for you if you
thought for even a second about is $100
worth buying this thing this is not for
you uh and it's been so much fun because
I segmented my audience and I'm talking
about like okay what are your favorite
things you've ever splurged on right
like uh a VIP tour at Disneyland for
like your family and friends one
audience would be like that is absurd
that you spent $44,000 you know or
whatever you're spending $500 an hour
for someone to help you cut the lines at
Disneyland but then some other person is
going to be like this is amazing like
how do I you know how do I book that
what other tips do you have
and even little things like there's
people in my life
um who have helped me reframe things
around money in a really important way
and I want to be able to pass that on um
like my friend Mark at one point was
talking about um investing like I assume
that once you get to a certain level
then like investing gets really
complicated you have to have like
financial advisors and you have to you
know you like you have all these new
opportunities and so it means all this
stuff and he's like look we were talking
about it and he built up uh I think his
his Vanguard investing account to about
$5 million from his creator business
just continually you know for a decade
putting in hundreds and hundreds of
thousands dollars a year just funneling
all those profits in and I was like but
don't you have to do more complicated
things he's like no the Vanguard account
functions the same at 100 Grand and 500
Grand and 5 million like it just works
the same like it it doesn't matter it's
like well isn't that a ton of money to
keep in Vanguard he's like no think of
the grand scale like they're like $5
million doesn't even register for that
you know they probably have billions of
billions of dollars in single Vanguard
accounts yeah uh and another moment when
convertkit first got a million dollars
in in our checking account right to
operate the business and you know all
that we we'd saved up to that point and
I asked in this software founder slack
group um like what do I do what fan like
what do I need to set up this is all
that and this guy Ian who runs a really
successful uh SAS company just said like
Nathan a million dollars is a very
normal amount of money to have in a
checking account for a business and I
was like what but don't you and I
realize like oh yeah that's just how
businesses operate so there there's
these conversations around money that I
wanted to be able to write out and I
wanted to do it in two ways I wanted to
do it where I can create something once
and it continues to work for me forever
so I'm not on a Content treadmill and
where people are like Nathan where's
this week's essay or something like that
uh and then the second thing is I wanted
to do it to a niche enough audience that
they would care about and value the same
things and I wouldn't have any of the
like here's Nathan bragging about
something related to money yeah right
and so I think that tool of like an
email course or a private section of
your blog or something else is really
great for that because you can explore
what you care about Niche it down to
only the people who care about that and
those are also my favorite replies right
like uh I'll write one on like my
favorite splurges once you have money
and then I just say like hey what are
your favorite splurges and people will
reply and say oh this one time I we took
another couple on this uh like was like
a a bikes and barges Cruise throughout
like a river cruise throughout Europe
where you like rode your bike all day
from one city to another like stopping
and then you like got back on the you
know River Cruise Boo and stayed for the
evening and it like repeated over and
over again they're like it was an
amazing experience and yeah it cost I
don't know $10,000 or or some really
meaningful amount of money but they're
like but it was amazing so I love
reading all of those stories and getting
the replies and I featured the replies
in future editions um of the the
newsletter so it makes this little
community so that's the way that I
handle it of like being able to write
the niche topics that I care about and
just segment it to a niche audience
that's really good I'm going to sign up
to the secret money newslet um yeah cuz
I I I heard some heard or read somewhere
might one of your podcast is is this the
same newsletter where you where you
reveal like personal income details and
all that kind of stuff yeah I have uh
about once a year I have like an update
of this is my net worth and where I
invest everything and interesting yeah
cuz I want to write about that stuff the
other thing is I want to read back all
my own previous stuff right I write a
year in review blog post for the last I
think TW I think I'm 12 years in of
writing you know you just Nathan
b.com like 2012- review 2022 revie
you'll get there and I'll even pull up
stuff like I wanted to show some on a
photo the other day and I was like I
know the URL structure of my blog so I
can get to that like
but those are written for me because I'm
like oh what was I struggling with in
2013 what what did I value in 2017 where
did I go right I'll go and look through
all of that oh there's the kids when
they were really little there's you know
all these different things and so yeah
I'm just creating content for me and
trying to have that archive I just also
put it out in the internet because I
guess I'm weird like that that's cool
that's very cool yeah cuz I've been
doing these videos for the last five
years or so about how much money I make
on YouTube each year and they're getting
more and more and I'm kind of like uh I
don't know if I want to continue doing
these in a way it does sort of paint a
Target on my back to some degree because
people might think that business revenue
is equivalent to personal money in the
bank which is really not and you need to
get like kidnapped outside your fire
that's the sort of thing I don't want
that to happen especially if I get
married have kids and things um but I
like I do like the idea of being public
and transparent about stuff like this
there is a point that it that it becomes
entirely
unrelatable um and so that like I I
wonder the same thing um like for conver
you know we public with our metrics but
our business has gotten a lot more
complicated or sophisticated and so now
like our public dashboard only shows you
know one Revenue line and we have three
and you know and then I'm thinking about
like okay is this still serving the same
same Journey so yeah sometimes yeah it's
it's a balance um and I don't know and
especially because you're right people
don't understand money they're like okay
oh you made $5 million off of this
that's absurd you know so you probably
took home like $4 million and you're
like
no I wish that is not how it works at
all um
so yeah there's definitely a
point where you would stop and one thing
that I would say because I've struggled
with this just to make clear yeah is you
don't owe this to anyone M right there
there's a point where if you create
content for a long period of
time people will start to treat you like
you owe them that you continue to create
that content yeah true and you don't
like do it for as long as it serves you
in that way and you can change people be
like oh o why are you not releasing that
video anymore like you know and you're
just like look it wasn't interesting to
me it wasn't serving me or or the
business and you know if you need that
road map look at the last six years of
this video that I put
um I I also wonder
about this is kind of uh a struggle for
me on like how much lifestyle things to
share of here's my fancy house yeah
here's my fancy house or uh if you
Charter a plane to go somewhere right or
or um you know who knows private tour at
Disneyland or like all these things a
fancy
car it's a weird thing where I like
don't on one hand don't feel like
sharing any of that stuff but on the
other hand if you do share it like it
drives um like lots of attention right
like my friend Dan Martell uh just
bought his own plane right and he
doesn't live that far from me like right
you know it's like a 10hour drive yeah
you know but like commercial whites is
ridiculous to uh to get there where is
up in Canada and like Colona Colona yeah
I've been trying trying to plan a trip
there but it's a [__] nightmare to
get to it's really really want get on
the podcast and like
his new Vlog and all the stuff yeah yeah
it's so much good
stuff and so I imagine I haven't talked
to him about this but I imagine when he
bought the plane you know there's a
whole thing of like oh should I share
this you know like that puts that's a
different level of wealth but then on
the other hand in sharing it he's
getting a whole bunch more attention
because there's someone scrolling
through Instagram like he owns a plane
who is this guy yeah right and they dive
in they find his stuff and they end up
like using his his advice to SC their
business and I all that so that's
something that
I struggle with a bit is at what level
to share that cuz on one hand I um like
live a pretty simple straightforward
life on a farm in boisey uh and then on
the other like there's things that I
spend absur amounts of money on and I'm
I absolutely love it and so it's like oh
you know like do I need a marketing
photo like that you know uh not that I
have a Lamborghini but if you did that
or like a Ferrari or something right you
could get a lot of marketing mileage out
of that yeah and I'm like I don't know
so you got to figure out what what your
brand is and and what you want to share
yeah yeah at one point I was doing
like you know I did a a tour of my
apartment in Cambridge which was cheap
it was like 1,500 a month rent uh or
yeah or the or the rent equivalent and
then I moved to London and I moved into
a fancier one and I was like okay let's
do a clickbait title and even though it
was renting we we called it like my my
$2.5 million apartment tour Y and there
was something about that I was just like
oh this oh God and like now this place
is even more expensive than that but
I've not mentioned it while I haven't
really talked about the price unless
someone's explicitly asked me on the
podcast and I like the idea of being I
like the James Clear approach kind of
the James Clear approach is basically I
want to be known for my ideas I don't I
don't I don't want to be known for my
face or like my lifestyle or anything
like that even though making [__] tons
of money um but at the same time I do
like I do like I've VI with your thing
about the whole transparency side and
sharing and you
know the fact that like down if you know
Dan Martell talks about how he how he
has a plane I'd be like I'm way more
likely to follow his stuff and I'd be
interested because I'm like oh [__] I'm
not thinking of that as him bragging I'm
thinking of it that's really cool that's
inspiring but I know that there are a
lot of people out there I speak to my
grandma I was Ching to her yesterday and
she was like oh Olie please talk about
stop talking about how much money you
make and I was like oh but it's
inspiring to people and I so many people
have said to me that like because of
that video they started a YouTube
Channel and she's like yeah but you know
everyone else out there is just sort of
feeling they're not feeling inspired
they're feeling like hurt because they
haven't achieved that and I'm just like
oh yeah I don't know I don't know yeah
and it's challenging right because you
don't know and you can't control how
someone's going to react to your content
and whether someone's going to say like
uh like I feel envious of that or
someone who goes oh I could do that
right so years
ago actually before I published the
aptis handbook I was wanting to write
and I like kind of start and stop and
you know working on this ebook and then
on the same day these two guys uh Jared
Dale and Sasha grief published ebooks
self-published ebooks to small audiences
about design and it was pure chance they
launched both of these on Hacker News on
the same day Sasha had this like it was
like a design case study where he walked
you through how it went and he sold it
for for I think $6 and then if you
wanted to buy like the one with the
Photoshop files with it it was $12 so we
had these two two prices and Jared sold
his book for
$39 and it was just that one price and
it was fascinating to see both of these
happen on the same day and it was like
you know you're like looking at them
ranked in Hacker News and you're like
that's that's
interesting and then Jason Cohen who's
the founder of WP engine invited both of
them to come on his blog
and say like write a write a guess post
about your pricing model how your launch
went and like why your pricing model is
better than the other person right
that's fun uh and so it's great fun and
so I read both of those he published
them like one after the other I read
both of them and thought a couple things
one you can make money self-publishing
two these guys are just like me they're
designers with small audiences you know
self-publishing a fairly Niche product
compar compared to like reading about
Jason freed who's like oh look we made
500 Grand self-publishing you should
too and so it really resonated with me
and I've heard a lot of other stories of
people saying like Okay like I'm paying
attention to the story and like there's
a black woman like me who accomplished
that there's this person who lives in my
country who accomplished this thing
right and seeing that representation and
I think that's just really really cool
because you can see it and go like uh
that could be
me and so I really like the
idea of sharing the stories ultimately
and being like this is the scale that it
could get right like you could build a
business to $5 million a year $10
million a year and it's possible because
that's the power of audiences and that's
why I love telling all this because
otherwise people don't realize how far
it can go but then it's a trade-off you
know you just don't know how people will
respond um I haven't really heard of
examples of people having truly negative
outcomes you know like yeah the Tim FIS
blog post is scary but other than that
that's true that's true and that is
right that is another level that's like
that's a whole five levels up from where
I for example but if you think about I
don't know how many copies of his books
Tim has sold but if we go to James CLE
for example he sold 15 million copies of
atomic habits um he has I think the
largest sing author newsletter on the
internet um and that's that's pretty
wild you but but he doesn't seem to have
like he seems to stay much more in the
background yeah but also like most
people who have read Atomic habits
probably don't know what he looks like M
so his his like profit per unit Fame is
quite strong yeah you know so we host a
conference every year called craft and
commerce and so we've had a lot of big
names you know James is spoken at and
Seth Goden and um
um one year we had uh Casey neistat come
out to speak 2018 I think um 2019
somewhere in there so he was like pretty
close to the peak of his like Vlog
popularity and and all that putting out
a ton of content before he kind of like
switched up his uh his stuff and took a
little bit of a
break and so he arrived at the airport
in boy Idaho and like someone on our
team went and picked him up and all that
and even like he was starting to get
mobbed
like and then you know just like waiting
curbside in boisey right people like
Casey Casey you know like trying to get
his attention all of that and uh you
know so watching like that level of
recognition him getting recognized very
randomly and and that level of Fame was
one thing and then uh the next year Mark
Manson came out to speak and this he uh
the subtle art would had like sold an
absurd number of copies was you know top
five New York Times list
continually and Mark attended the entire
conference like Not only was he at the
speakers dinner but he and his wife were
like they went to workshops they they
just like Mark is a very chill guy and
uh they loved it and then he got up and
gave his clothing
keynote and I think a bunch of people
went I had lunch with that guy that's
Mark Manson but it's the difference
between YouTube where your bases on
everything and you have that level of
Fame and the book where you're like oh I
could think that's an amazing book and
have no idea what Mark looks like now
what I wonder is over the last year or
so at least as I've noticed it Mark has
a lot of stuff a lot of content that
he's putting out with his face on it and
so I'm always curious uh I wonder what
thoughts you have on it of like that is
Mark giving up something like he had the
level of Fame and name recognition mhm
that maybe so many people want without
the face recognition I don't know maybe
he wants to get recognized on the street
maybe there's another type of content
that he wants to truly have his face I
do it what do you think yeah yeah um so
I I I had dinner with him in in La a
couple months ago um and he was very
kind enough to offer a blow up from my
book which which which was very nice uh
super chill guy really friendly um it it
was interesting how CU because I kind of
said to him that like he he is where I I
aspire to be in terms of like the book
stuff and the book is still sold
stupidly well etc etc um and he seems to
be trying to be a YouTuber and
succeeding fairly well at being a
YouTuber and he said he kind of said
that like you know with all the
traditional Media stuff the Hollywood
film and everything that it's it it
reaches more people it's more fun and it
makes more money to just make YouTube
videos H I was like okay that's
interesting um and he was kind of saying
to me that like don't Peg yourself worth
on like whether you hit the New York
Times best set list or not because
you'll do it maybe maybe not like you'll
change your Instagram bio and your
Twitter bio and life will move on and
it'll just be a minor blip and you won't
really care but it's like the work is
the thing right and so I was like that
was it was quite reassuring yeah but I
don't know how he feels about being
recognized in public and stuff yeah I
don't do you get recognized in public
very often yeah uh like a few times a
day if I'm roaming around London okay I
quite like it cuz that feels like a good
level
it's educational content so people are
like nice about it and like it's only
really nerds who follow my stuff and so
like chances are I want to talk to them
about about something um but I wouldn't
want it to be like in an entertainment
kind of Z genre where there's like a
line of a hundred people trying to get
to you and you're like trying to be like
yeah um I think it's all yeah different
different gen as well like who's it um
MKBHD Marcus brandley was was talking
about how he would you know he was at
the this YouTuber event with like lelay
pwns or somethingone like that and sort
of she uh she walked out the airport and
there was like a mob of like a 100
people like just waiting he walked out
of the same airport no one recognized
him and he's got like 15 million
subscribers is like the world's biggest
Tech YouTuber yeah but also the sorts of
people that that watch his channel are
not the sort of people that would like
line up outside someone's hotel room to
figure out oh my God Marquez is is here
so I think this what outfit is he
wearing today what you
know um of wealth the ladders of wealth
creation a step-by-step road map to
what's it to Building Wealth
um yeah so I guess the first one is yeah
you know there there's these four
different things I wonder if we can just
sort of talk through these in turn and
just love for you to Riff on these
because yeah so in the ladders of wealth
I break down like four different ladders
then you can climb as high as you want
on any ladder but they are I guess some
some are ultimately taller than others
um so to run through quickly time for
money uh your own Services business
product as services and then ultimately
selling products and as as we think
about skills the skills that you have to
learn are pretty different on each
ladder so time for money you might think
like what skills do you have to learn
for that but you know going back to the
job at Wendy's there's a lot of people
who did not learn the time for money
skills those are like being able to
follow a process doing what you're told
showing up to work on time showing up to
work so
you know like some of these these things
that uh we might take for granted but
like for a lot of people you have to
actually learn that to be reliable and
to be consistent and so in that ladder
you're going to start with like an
hourly job um you know it could be
Landscaping could be Wendy's could be
something else uh and then later move up
to a salary job and you're going to have
a pretty big range within that right
there's plenty of salary jobs that would
be on that ladder that could get to
$200,000 a year you know maybe even as
high as a million dollars a year that
that could be within that um the next
lad I think is where things start to get
more complicated right that's like
having your own Services business at the
basic level you're talking about
operating as a freelancer right um and
so that's where I'm just you know
trading time for money both of these
first two ladders are time for money and
and there's a onetoone relationship
there and and so but in the services
business I have to know how to form a
company right like how to fire the file
the paperwork with the government I have
to know okay I got to work with an
accountant I can't just use like Turbo
Tax or some other software right there's
some more stuff for that um how to how
to write contracts you know all of those
things so the first rung in that ladder
is really like hourly work hey I'll
design your website for $50 an hour I'll
show up for this amount of time you know
or I'll mow your lawn for $25 an hour
anything like that
the next lad the next Rong in the ladder
is when you start to charge by the
project and this is where things get
interesting because now you have this
big disconnect or a possible disconnect
and a leverage point and you've
separated time for money instead of I I
will design your site for $50 an hour
it's I'll design your site for uh
$2,000 no matter how many hours it takes
M and now we've introduced leverage and
you understand uh leverage a lot of
people are like oh Leverage is good and
I have to remind them like Leverage is
neither good nor bad it just is and it
just amplifies what already is going to
happen yeah right so if I am investing
and I borrow money that gives me
leverage to be able to invest more that
means that I'm going you know if the
stock goes up I'm going to make more
money than I would have otherwise and if
the stock goes down I'm going to lose
more money than I would have otherwise
sure so in our web design example um
maybe it takes me 10 hours and I end up
making the equivalent of $200 an hour
maybe it takes me hours and I make far
less than I should you know um so
that that's the first thing once you
disconnect time for money
then you start to get leverage and then
the last rung on that ladder on the uh
Services ladder is really like managing
a team and that's a whole new set of
skills and you can get even more
leverage so at each of these two ladders
you can make a lot of money and you need
to learn one set of skills or I guess
differ of skills and you can get
increasing amounts of Leverage and then
really as you move across uh to other
ladders then uh like product as Services
then it get really interesting I guess
to to run through them quickly the
product services are interesting because
you're you're trying to take something
that was totally flexible MH and you're
saying let me standardize it more and
more so I can move more people through
the process I can have it's easier for
team members to provide this value like
uh hey friends for example is a good
example what did you if you explain
really quick hey friends is is an agency
that we're building um with with a
couple of Partners basically
it's if if people sign up and they pay
large amounts of money like I think
starting at $14,000 a month then uh the
agency will do all of the work to make
them Banger YouTube videos that kind of
look like mine I.E the talking to a
camera talking head educational videos
where all like for example Nathan if you
wanted to do YouTube through hey friends
all you would to do is show up and talk
to a camera for like a handful of videos
we would do the titles the thumbnails
the ideation we would say Nathan we've
analyzed all your work we've figured out
your style we figured out your goals
these are the videos we want you to film
you would just record to a camera send
us the files and then our team would do
all of the work in turning them into
sick videos with great editing and Good
Vibes and deal with all the analytics
and everything and so that is a producti
service in that we have basically
converted my process for making videos
into a standardized Playbook that team
members can follow we'll plug in your
goals and your brand aesthetic and
everything into that and then we can
then sell it out at a discount compared
to what it would be to create that
completely from scratch yeah yeah so
it's no longer perfectly bespoke but in
a lot of ways it benefits from the fact
that it's not because you're you're
being able to take the wins that you
have across clients and and things you
learn in the process and and and go from
there so what's interesting about
product I Services is that you usually
go from selling them uh one to one right
like I'm not taking you out to coffee
and then saying like oh here's all we
can do and like that is one skill set
that you need to learn in a Services
business but as you get productize it's
like oh now I need to disconnect the
sales I need to be able to sell through
a sales page and so for that I I have to
learn copywriting and design and maybe
WordPress or conver landing pages or
whatever else to build up like to make
that sale without my time and then on
the the services as aspect of it we're
trying to standardize as much as
possible there so we have as much
leverage so in each case we're like it
goes from very connected and then we're
just gradually trying to disconnect okay
how the service is delivered how it's
sold and we're getting further and
further apart because in each case that
allows uh for more leverage yeah and
then as you take that further right um
hey friends is a is a recurring offering
right and that that's another point of
Leverage because wait a second I sell
this one time as long as I keep
delivering value consistently then
they're going to stay on I'm not having
to make a new sale every single month
and so that's a huge thing and then then
the final ladder is really where you're
going to to Pure products and so that
could be something as simple as an ebook
like we've talked about it could be like
a WordPress plugin uh even like a an
Airbnb is a is a product that you've
made right it's disconnected um and so
like WordPress Shopify uh Airbnb all
that that are products inserted into an
existing marketplace right like I own
several
airbnbs and I don't think about how do I
Market them I think about how do I make
my listing good and then Airbnb takes
care of all that deal flow so that's an
easier product to make than a product
where you have to like create and
package and sell and then continually
market and have your own um uh you know
continual sales to to scale that up so
that that you know things get harder and
harder on the ladder and then ultimately
I think that
um uh software is a service is one of
the most difficult things uh to do but
also one of the highest value because
when it gets implemented into a company
it sticks around for a very very long
time and then you know you see them Get
Ridiculous multiples and all that and
then ultimately I think the hardest
thing to build and the highest possible
Leverage is like a Marketplace or a
social network where and what's funny is
a bunch of people start there right
they're like I have this idea for you
know a dog walking service and blah BL
you know and you're like that that's a
two-sided Marketplace and so you have
the skills that you should be operating
like on ladder one Rong one and you're
saying like let me dive all the way in
and try to tackle the like the absolute
top of the last ladder and that's why uh
people really struggle because they they
try to bite off way too much and they
they try to make a leap that requires
learning you know 50 skills instead of
yeah iterating through one sko at a time
yeah I when I when I first read your
read this essay I I I thought it mapped
quite well onto what I was doing with my
life so like I started off trading time
for money when I was like 12 and doing
like private tutoring for like £45 an
hour y um then I moved into selling
services which was like Web Design
Services where I was charging by the
hour um and then moved into charging by
the project and didn't really make very
much money from it then slowly started
dabbling with the product thing so my
first proper business that was
successful was uh sort of Med schooled
admissions business where I was doing
selling inperson courses teaching people
how to get into med school and initially
I was doing them all myself but then we
sort of turned it into like a a process
that like I could hire people to follow
and then I built a sort of software
medical school question bank because I
knew how to code and com combine forces
with my brother and then that was a
product with some level of recurring
revenue and then the YouTube channel
came and the courses on on top of that
and so now it's like almost everything
we do we try and do in the products Camp
um and I don't like going back into
product High service it's like hey
friends was nice because we didn't have
to do anything for it so to us it was
like basically a product but the team is
managing managing everything and we do
have a bit of a service based offering
for our YouTuber accelerator which is a
little bit service but that's more like
a product but just like good customer
customer service and so now I it's just
like having gone through the the three
different ladders and on to ladder four
it's like that is where the true gains
are to be had um yeah yeah depend in the
goal like I actually was fairly against
uh Services as like an ideal business
but I think the more that I've gotten
into that world and paid attention to it
there are some very very like truly
fantastic Services businesses uh at both
crazy scale and uh much smaller like I
always thought it hit some limit um but
after seeing like behind the scenes of
some of these service businesses that
are doing like 10 to 20 million a year
in profit then you're like oh okay so
what really interesting about that is a
lot of products you end up with a low
average revenue per user so if we take
your um like productivity consumer app
right if we it'll be a low average Reven
per user yeah so you might be making
$100 per year per user something like
that right that's very different than if
we're charging $10,000 a month for um um
an agency service right that's
$100,000 per reeven uh you average
revenue per
user and so it takes really a lot of
individual app subscriptions to add up
to you know even a handful of the agency
subscriptions and so it really depends
on your goals right if you're trying to
maximize Enterprise Value basically the
the equity value of what you could sell
this for then you might really focus on
the appside but if you're trying to Max
maximize you know cash flow both short
and long term then the agency could be a
much better model and then especially
realizing that they're not mutually
exclusive this is something that sill
Bloom is very good at right where he's
saying oh I'm gonna start this and this
and this and he asked the question like
what would have to be true for me to be
able to run multiple
agencies without that being a huge drain
on my time right like for him protecting
his writing time is the most important
thing uh in his business and so he's
like great I just can't can't run any of
the agencies right and he and I have an
agency together um called paper boy
which is a newsletter growth agency and
we collectively like he and I each spend
maybe an hour or two a month on it
because you know we hired a CEO and so
when we ma it out from the beginning it
was like okay well it has to be true for
us to focus on our core thing have it
feed into it um and then still provide
this really valuable service and so it's
all just all on how you design it one
thing that you've been uh right and I
guess thinking about a lot recently is
um the billion dooll Creator and I think
that relates to the idea of sort of fly
wheels when it comes to Creator stuff I
wonder what what what is all this stuff
yeah the idea behind the billion dollar
Creator which is another one of these
essays that I wrote is if you have
attention which creators are so good at
getting attention like you get to point
it somewhere and so what's the highest
Roi place you would point that attention
a simple example you you know most
creators are saying okay let me sell an
ebook let me sell a course uh affiliate
products and we're blown away right that
you can make $1,000 10,000 $100,000 a
million dollars off of an audience and
like this is amazing and mind-blowing
but as people who are always trying to
push the limits and know it's possible
we're like what what else could we do
and what I wonder is could you build a
hundred million business so an example
that I love is this guy Mark Sison who
he created a Blog called Mark's Daily
Apple uh maybe 20 9 2010 uh time period
And if you think about when the paleo
diet um started to really become popular
they they were focused on uh recipes and
content in that Niche and he built this
blog to the point that I think it was
making over a million dollars a year
which is just absolutely
incredible and you might think like okay
that's the Pinnacle of what you can do
with a Blog and what Mark ended up doing
is he said what else can I offer to this
community and so we thought like
wouldn't it be really nice if you could
have a um like a mayonnaise or a ketchup
or things that match the paleo diet and
so he started his own company making
that called Primal kitchen and you know
got his recipes manufactured all of that
and used his audience you know of a
couple hundred thousand people on an
email newsletter in this Niche to like
drive his first sales and then as it
went from there he was trying to get
distribution grocery stores and I don't
know the exact details but I imagine
what happened is things like like
getting in Whole Foods for the very
first time they're like um sure we'll
see if people buy this we'll like give
you one bit of placement in this one
store in Austin right well what he does
is you just go into your Emil tool say
like okay let's target everyone who
lives within 50 miles of that store and
then you're like why don't you go buy uh
this you know hey or like great news
Prim Kitchen products are now in this
Whole Foods location go buy it in person
right and then a week later you talk to
your Whole Foods rep and you're like so
uh you know how'd that little test do
you put it in like a couple stores how'd
that go and they're like it went
incredible like people get sold out
instantly really oh that's that's
fascinating I love that the product is
resonating you know and it's like well
no you use your audience to Kickstart
that so they can spread through they get
more distribution and expand from there
um using the power of audience the short
of the story is in two years uh they
sold Primal kitchen to craft foods for
$150 million my God and so when you
think about okay if you have all of
these people who are like close or big
fans of a
topic you can direct that attention to
affiliate products courses ebooks that
kind of thing or in the case Marx isn't
it he's like no I'm going to create a
consumer product at a massive scale and
it's like okay A Blog can be worth you
know hundreds of millions um uh Emily
Weiss created this this blog called into
the gloss about fashion right and so
that was her topic that she cared about
and like okay a fashion blog what could
that be worth probably a decent amount
but ended up being the thing that
kickstarted her company glossier oh
that's her company yeah oh in common
Garden I saw it yesterday yeah right can
a Blog build into something worth a
billion dollars yes if you think about
things in the right way way and so you
have to focus on products that um you
know have built a lot of value or uh can
be sold to many many people or often
purchased in a recurring way uh if we go
to in the celebrity world like if you
think Ryan Reynolds he's someone who's
like um I'd rather not get paid 500
Grand or a million bucks for a TV
commercial I'd rather buy a company like
mintmobile or Aviation gin and then use
my marketing Acumen and you know face to
promote those and have all the equity
value and you know he sold Aviation Jin
I think for 7 or 800 million uh me
mobile he sold for 1.3 billion to
T-Mobile right and so he's not like he's
not doing basically a paid sponsorship
to be on a TV commercial he's like nope
I'm going to do it where I get capture
the full Equity value and there's
example after example and people focus
on them in the celebrity world yeah but
it's happening non-stop in the Creator
world in the same way and that's a topic
that I'm absolutely obsessed with and I
guess just to give one more example
that's what I'm doing with convertkit
right I can take my uh podcast my
content my network all of that and I
could focus it on books and courses and
that's a great way to make 500,000 or a
million dollars a year or ultimately I
can Channel all of that into building
convert as a software company that's now
at 40 million a year in revenue and you
know uh worth a few hundred million and
then like my goal that's the the promise
behind the billion dollar Creator my
goal is to build that into a company
worth a billion dollars um and it's just
the same thing what's the best Roi place
I can direct that
attention it's absolutely wild
um the interview I did with Dan uh Dan
Priestley on this podcast came out a
couple of days ago so I was re listening
to that he is sort of a serial
entrepreneur here in the UK he is um and
he's also very bullish on the he was
like he was saying to me Ali look you
can screw around with course is all you
like but if you if you owned a business
that if you owned a business outside of
your YouTube channel business and
directed traffic to that or even owned a
minority Equity stake in a business and
directed traffic to that and that
business then exit exits in one
transaction you could make the same
amount of money as you would make in a
lifetime of selling courses correct and
I was like yeah I know I know that's
right but to me it that's just seems
like you know if I if I look at someone
like sahill it's he's he's got the
background in private equity and like
Investment Banking and all that [__] and
for him it probably seems easy to be
like oh I guess I'll just build a
business and hire an operator and stuff
to me that's such a black box right
where I'm like I don't know anyone who
could do that but I as I'm saying that I
mean like it wouldn't be that hard to
find out I could literally spend a day
just like going through people I know
who follow me on Twitter and be like hey
want to do this thing want to hop on a
call get some advice from the people
that I know put out a message to my
newsletter and be like hey who wants to
partner up in building one of these
things like right it would be very
doable I don't know why I'm not doing it
yeah just feels feels scary feels hard
feels like a black box don't really know
I'm very comfortable in the course's
business well there's a timing thing as
well right it would be very easy for
someone to listen to the what we're
doing here and maybe they have say
50,000 subscribers on YouTube 100,000
right something that is a very
meaningful Milestone and and a huge
audience like I always someone's like oh
100,000 isn't big I'm like look at like
the largest football stadium like that's
100,000 people you know
um it'd be easy to look at that and go
okay forget courses forget all these
other things I am going to go build the
next Primal kitchen I'm going to go
build um the next M mobile or whatever
and that would be jumping like three
ladders attempting to jump three ladders
simult in like a single leap yeah and
that is a pretty sure way to to fail
right and so instead what you're doing
you're iterating through all of these
things right you have learned to build a
team five years ago I don't think you
knew how to build and manage a team no
right and you got to do it in a little
bit lower Stakes environment you didn't
take all of your savings from the
YouTube channel and say like we're going
to pour this into an app Y and we spent
a million dollars building out this app
and it totally flopped because we did I
didn't know how to build and manage a
team right and so a part of the ladders
of wealth creation article is to think
about the skills that you need in order
to do this and and deliberately chunk
away at them right and
so that's the
thing it I I think it be totally fine to
say like oh I am not ready for
this I want to get ready for it so maybe
the like building hey friends as an
agency is one of the is a key building
block for you in those skills because
you're like wait this would be the first
time that I have a business that's
making substantial cash flow and
requires very little time for me that's
something for um paper boy my agency
with sahill and then Shane our
CEO that was really weird to me so I
showed up to a call about like the next
steps we we launched it we' done a bunch
of things and I showed up to an update
call we talked through it we helped
Shane with some key decisions he was
trying to make and then I left and what
was really weird to me is that I did not
have a single to-do item coming out of
that call whereas with convertkit I am
like deeply embedded in all these things
and I realized like oh I've like put
myself in this too much and it's holding
things back so a key learning for me is
like wait I can have a successful
business that I don't spend meaningful
time
on and I'm still kind of sitting with
that cuz that was just like a month ago
yeah and you're like
wait so so going to a journaling prompt
right how could convertkit be more
successful if I spent less time on it
and you're like it couldn't like my time
is wildly valuable all of this I have a
huge impact everywhere I go whatever we
want say about ourselves but then I
think about I'm like okay well I could
Empower my team more I could make the
vision more clear I could step out of
the weeds you know like there's so many
things in that
um and so I think these are just skills
that we build and develop over time and
so I think in your case it might be
totally fine to say like oh I am not
ready for this
level because there's either skills that
I want to continue to build or a certain
level of comfort yeah and then make a
road map what would have to be true for
you to feel ready at that point what
small steps could you make is there a
business that you could come in and say
like hey I'd love to buy 10% of your
business for 100 grand and uh then I
will also actively promote it and get a
REV share from it right like there might
be something that that you could push on
that level and you could try it out and
then end up with this portfolio business
so like how could you ease in rather
than take a big leap that's a really
good point yeah at the moment I'm think
I I think I think I'm thinking of it as
All or Nothing But actually
just as he was saying that I was
thinking instead of thinking of hey
friends as oh I don't need to do
anything that's a great learning
opportunity I could just actually take
more of an interest and like okay I
wonder how this actually working like
what's going on here treat that as a bit
of a learning learning thing um yeah
like T um Hunter who's the the CEO of
like that whole company like how does he
build teams how would he you know what
what traits are you seeing
um if you were to look for another
operator for an entirely different
business what could you learn from
watching him um all of those things are
are really really
interesting how do fly wheels fit into
this whole oh fly wheels are are
probably like my biggest Obsession right
now um so do you think your audience
knows what a flywheel is should we
explain it let's define it yeah let's
define it yeah so I first encountered a
flywheel in 2008 I was in lutu which is
the Little Country oh no way that's
where I used to live really yeah I lived
there for like six years growing up okay
where in M okay so I was in miseru no
way that is very very random yeah um
most people are like L what where where
is that where is and they're like oh
that's that country inside South Africa
um so we family friends who uh lived
around um South Africa in litu and and
uh so we got to do a trip with them uh
and go visit and and did some work at
this orphanage um and we put in it like
had a well drilled and we were
installing you know we need some kind of
pump on top of it at the time in 2008
the uh like electricity wasn't super
consistent and so they didn't want to
put an electric pump in there they
wanted a hand operated pump which if you
think about from
a you know like at least near where I
live you'd go to a campground there'd be
like this hand pump that you know is is
a pretty works fine for camping for the
weekend you would not want like 100 kids
being relying on that for for walk
so instead we install a flywheel which
is this big metal wheel that sits on top
and instead of having this like up and
down linear action that a pump has it
has a rotating action and so it it move
it turns continuously Y and so once we
got it all set up um like it was really
hard to move at first like my friend
Luke and I both like we on each side of
it on the handles like turning it it's
very difficult to get going and then
what we did like over time it starts to
speed up and gain momentum and gets
easier and what that allowed us to do is
like then he steps away and he's no
longer turning it and I can turn it by
myself and then I can turn it with one
hand and then you know by the end I keep
the momentum going with one finger
because it's this continuous thing and
the the metal wheel like the inertia of
that carries
forward and so when you think about it
from a business perspective most things
that we do are the hand pump version
there's a direct correlation to how much
effort we put in and how much results
that we get out right every pump down
there's a spirit of
water and flywheels are
fascinating because they almost sound
too good to be true like I've defined it
as three laws for a flywheel the first
thing is that every action flows
smoothly into the next right it's this
it finishes in a loop the second is that
uh it should get easier with every
rotation right every time you turn it it
gets easier and then the third thing is
every time every rotation it actually
produces more and in an abstract
business sense you're like this is too
good to be true you're saying this gets
easier with time and produces more
that's insane but it actually works in
real life physics right and I I know
firsthand of how hard that was to turn
at first and how little water I got and
then by the end I'm just standing there
spinning it one hand it's so easy
so I am now absolutely obsessed with uh
with flywheels of how can I apply this
all throughout my business and how can I
help creators apply this so I want to go
both on a very small scale and then on a
very large
scale let's take for example writing a
newsletter every
week on one hand it's not that hard on
the other hand you're like shoot what do
I even write about and if you're working
through a list of ideas or or it's
scattered then you're
like you know trying to figure it's
Monday night the newsletter goes out
Tuesday morning you're like what what
should I even write about I'm running
out of
ideas if you have a flywheel around
content
ideas then it can completely change the
game so let's say that if we map out
this flywheel new people are signing up
for my newsletter
yep and I send them a few welcome emails
and like in the third or fourth welcome
email I ask them a question and I say
hey what is your biggest frustration
with learning to scale your YouTube
channel right that's what we're teaching
on this newsletter
then hit reply and let me know people
hit reply and they say oh I'm really
struggling with how to make thumbnails
I'm really struggling with uh like
building up my content calendar you know
whatever it
is all of those replies you put into a
label in Gmail or you zapier to put into
something else and now when you're
saying okay what should I write about
this week you just go into those replies
and say oh John is struggling with
thumbnails let me write an answer to his
question and then make it a little more
generic so it fits for everybody and
that sent it out to the newsletter and
so the way this works in a flywheel is
people come in so basically the more
people who come in the more frustrations
I collect which gives me more ideas for
Content which as I publish that content
reaches more subscribers which gives me
more frustrations which giv you more
ideas content on on so this is a
continuous loop it gets easier with time
because we're getting more and more of
these questions uh and then it also
produces more because later each piece
of content is going to reach even more
people so early content might have
gotten five newsletter subscribers and
down the road content might get 500 new
newsletter subscribers so that's an idea
of taking something core in your process
and turning into a flywheel that's now
just running for you with some really
basic
automation if you think about on the
other end we talked about sill uh he is
really interesting to me because he's
grown a
newsletter to 500,000 subscribers in
three years two and a half years like
very very quickly and actually I think
he's only just over a year from 100,000
to
500,000 and it's all because of the
flywheel that he's built out and so the
way that this flywheel works is he has
new subscribers coming in from social so
you know Twitter Instagram and Linkedin
primarily as they come in he is um
selling sponsorships in his newslet so
actually conver has a whole advertising
division so we s the sponsorships in his
newsletter um he's got emails like
automated emails welc people do his
newsletter sharing his work um all of
that kind of thing and
then he's taking the money that he makes
from his sponsorship and spending it on
uh paid acquisition through uh another
company that we bought called spark Loop
which has his recommendations Network
and then that gets grows his newsletter
so in the simplest form the more
subscribers he has the more money he
makes on sponsorships which means he
invests more money in paid growth to
make his newsletter bigger which means
he's make more more money in
sponsorships which means he has more
money to invest yeah and so on and it's
it's pretty basic but like an early
rotation of this flywheel would get him
uh maybe $10,000 in sponsorships for the
month and um you know and then he he
reinvests that 10,000 uh and that might
get him 5,000 new subscribers
but now uh he's making 50 to 70,000 a
month in sponsorships hell and
reinvesting that yeah and growing even
faster so you just watch like the
snowball rolling down the hill getting
bigger and bigger and bigger um and it's
like getting easier with time it's
producing more and more results uh and
he's well on track to hit a million
subscribers you know in the next five
six months based on that which is crazy
to think ment he's now adding like a
100,000 email subscribers a month yeah
um and it's all because he's got this
aspect of his flywheel absolutely dialed
in and there you know there's things
with it of like other creators you
partners with and more and more that
goes into it but it basically trying to
take all these one-off tasks that you do
uh and turn them into a process that can
either run automatically um or you know
be operated by your team or something
that you can run uh in a pretty
straightforward way so I'm obsessed with
flywheels that's the
point it's good stuff you're like I I
see the diagrams writing newsletter all
yeah I'm just thinking like everything
is down fundamentally Downstream of
writing MH and all commercial activi a
fundamentally Downstream of the
newsletter I
think yeah one thing that I've done is I
love the design tool figma and so it has
this Infinite Canvas um and so so I like
to map out my flywheels in that like
okay what about this and I'll I'll
design the same thing in a bunch of
different ways and cuz I like playing
with hypotheticals of um like figuring
out what's the one driver of this
flywheel what's the thing
that makes the biggest impact and then
what if I had this other thing that was
the biggest
driver and so you can really just play
with like sketching this out or I have
all these components that I use in figma
to like move it around and and um um
just think about how could I how could I
tweak this flywheel and it forces you to
really simplify things about your
business that otherwise you just
wouldn't so like the sketch that you
started to make there that's exactly the
kind of thing that I I'll make like
dozens and dozens of flywheel sketches
oh man I've got to show you my fig Jam I
do the same thing like on a Sunday I'll
go to a coffee shop for 4 hours and just
literally draw boxes on fig Jam yeah
just be like how do I simplify our
business to only three metrics what are
the three that are really and this is
like yeah and then it'll it'll be really
simple it'll be like okay well views
equals newsletter Subs equals revenue
and like why was that complicated yeah
so then you have to close that Loop yeah
right if you want to make it a flywheel
is to go how does more Revenue drive
more views uh more Revenue drives more
profit profit gets reinvested into
business right and then you get specific
right okay that profit how exactly does
it get rein okay yeah that's what I
haven't done yet because I've just been
like oh generally but how it would do is
like if we can increase our output that
was that's one option but a completely
an option I've not even considered as
the SLE paid acquisition model yep where
actually putting money in gets you more
more views and stuff putting outs spend
behind our videos that we know will
convert to things like yeah yeah and and
like in a very simple way if you looked
at like Mr Beast spy wheel he's just
like great how much money did I make how
much can I pour this into making a
ridiculous video that's going to get
more attention right and and that that
uh compounded pretty quickly and so then
what I like to do is get to the point in
the fly whe where it's obvious like
first figure out how to close the loop
cuz most people get to a linear process
yeah right so closing the loop is really
really important and then force yourself
to come up with four or five different
ways to close the
loop right
um I had a very brief stint uh going to
college and I was in art school and I
didn't have a lot of good takeaways but
one thing that they would force you to
do is when you um planning out your art
in the early stages to do something
called thumbnailing and they just said
take a piece of paper like Fold It Up a
bunch and then un unfold it so you have
like you know 12 boxes or something of
of a small
size and like sketch out a particular
like uh composition for your landscape
or I used it a ton in designing apps
later on I'm like you know at the small
size what are 10 different ways that I
could design this app interface yep and
so I'd apply the same concept to fly
flywheels where it's say okay what if I
what if money and reinvesting profits
what if I'm not allowed to use that as
the loop closer or the engine of this
flywheel what else could I use and
that'll get me thinking through like
okay maybe it's relationships maybe
the like going on podcasts or something
else you know like partner webinars
maybe that turns into the thing um and
so I like to put in the these things in
the classics would be what if I'm not
allowed to reinvest any money in my
business what if I have to reinvest
every dollar that I make in my business
what if and you you play with those
constraints and you get to things that
you know you might get all the way back
to the exact same thing that you drw
that you drew out in the first place but
you'll be way more confident in it or
you might get to something entirely
different sick all right that's some
homework for me so a I'm committing
officially committing to doing a
thousand words a day um so I'll message
you and let you know how that goes May
that'll be so good if like just thinking
th words a day that's email newsletter
like i' never struggle with like you
know it's Sunday today so I need to send
my newsletter today and I don't have
anything written right I need to write
something today so that'll be a good
start but also things like Instagram
captions and stuff I always feel like I
have thoughts but
like I can't share those thoughts
because they're either in the newsletter
or they're compiled into like a sort of
full-on YouTube video production type
thing but actually if I just had the
stuff written I just have things i' like
to share chucking as an Instagram
caption or as a Twitter long form post
or something and then alongside also
progress on these like four different
book ideas and all of it would just
happen by default if I actually brought
a th words a day mental yep mental
simple not easy simple not easy all
right we got this Nathan thank you so
much um for anyone who's listened to the
last two and a half hours of this
conversation who Vibe with your way of
seeing the world any final parting words
of advice for anyone who's gotten this
far in the Pod oh man I think uh create
every day is probably the biggest thing
like if you embody that and you keep
learning continually
like make something put it out in the
world and try to learn from how it's you
know everything that happened there uh
that's the single biggest thing and then
everything else is is strategy
Downstream from from those habits so
don't over complicate it like we can
figure out all of the crazy Advanced
flywheels and how exactly we're making
the highest Roi from a single unit of
attention yeah later on but you got to
make sure that you have the creation
dialed in really uh way can people learn
more about you and your work if they
would like to find out more yeah let's
see uh if you go to Nathan b.com that's
all of my essays and and all of that uh
starting a new podcast called billion
doll Creator uh so get to nerd out on
all you know things like flywheels and
equity and everything else and then uh
any was not using convertkit should it's
just at convert.com we power all the
biggest newsletters on the internet yeah
including ours which is not very big but
well actually it's reasonable it's
reasonable about 500,000 Subs in total
that's that is a very large newsletter
nice I'm glad I'm glad to hear it um and
I realized that like you're actually
most famous for convertkit and we spent
basically zero time talking about
convert Kate so it' be great to do a
round two at some point and going
charting the 10e history of convert Kate
and the lessons you've learned along the
way that would be awesome for round two
um but yeah thank you so much for
joining yeah thanks for having me all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye